Ich meine, die Fallsysteme, die wir heute haben, vor allem natürlich auch HFS, ist halt gebaut für rotierende Platten. So und ich denke, es gibt eine ganze Menge Optimierungen, die man jetzt auch machen kann, schlicht in der Annahme, dass quasi der Speicher der Zukunft eben ohne diese Platten auskommt.
Also meiner Meinung nach wäre Apple Style schon zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt da mal SSD, so wie wir uns das vorstellen. Und da machen wir dann auch alles rein, was das neue Datalsystem ausmacht. Also das wäre Apple Style.
Ja gut, aber Apple Style ist auch Full-Disc encryption. Ja, aber was ist denn, wenn da die Bits kippen, dann funktioniert das nicht. Aber das ist ja eine Ebene drunter sowieso, oder? Ja, das weiß ich nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, mal probiert, ausgemacht, irgendwann nochmal probiert, wieder ausgemacht, seitdem irgendwie nicht mehr probiert, weil...
Ausgemacht? Wo hast du das ausgemacht?
Da kann man auch direkt an- und ausschalten.
In der Camera-App.
Ich glaube, du kannst es auch...
Jetzt kommt das Thema, erzähl uns was Neues.
Also, das Einzige, was jetzt wirklich anders ist, beim SE gegenüber dem 5S in meiner Nutzung. Ich starte diese Camera-App. Und weil halt jetzt Live-Foto ja im Prinzip so ein Mini-Video ist.
Ja, kann man erst mal eine Sekunde lang kein Foto machen. Oder was? Weil er erst mal das davor aufnehmen muss, bevor er dich erlaubt, dir erlaubt, ein Foto zu schießen.
Nee, das Problem ist, es handelt sich dabei ja um einen kurzen Film. Und da ist ja auch Audio dabei. Und weil da Audio dabei ist, muss er das Audio-Device aufmachen. Und weil er das Audio-Device aufmacht, um ein Mikrofon anzusprechen, stoppt Background-Audio.
Und du hörst ja Podcasts.
Genau. Das heißt, wenn ich während des Podcasts... Postcasts... Postcastens? Podcasts... während ich sozusagen durch die Gegend laufe, ein Podcast höre und denke so, oh hier mach ich mal ein Foto, muss ich für jedes scheiß Foto eine Pause...
Es gibt einen Trick...
.in der Wiedergabe. Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Es gibt einen Trick. Wie ist der?
Aber warte, ich hab das gleiche Problem.
Also nur Live-Fotos ausschalten geht nicht.
Der Trick ist, du machst das Foto in der Chat ab. Da macht dir das Background-Audio nicht aus. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Weil er da diesen Live-Fotograben nicht macht. Weil er macht dann nur ein normales Foto. In der Chat ab. Du meinst in Messages.
Weil ich hab das gleiche Problem. Ich hör ja mit meinem Sandheiser-Bluetooth-Kopfhörer und hör halt Musik, willst halt ein Foto machen und dann geht halt die Musik aus.
Ah, da ist ja auch dieser ganze andere Mumpitz nicht dabei. Also mit Panorama und so. Ja, dankeschön. Sie haben einen einfachen Podcast-Hörer. Sehr glücklich gemacht.
Na ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so ein guter Workaround ist.
Na ja, du hast halt da diverse Features nicht. Du kannst da nicht hier so HDR ein ausschalten, sondern nur Blitz und Kamerawechsel. Aber immerhin ist das schon mal eine. Ja, das ist schon mal eine große Sache. Oder halt irgendwelche anderen komischen Apps nehmen. Das Problem ist, wenn ich mein Telefon als Kamera benutze, dann häufig so dieses, oh, das muss ich jetzt aber schnell fotografieren. Weil, keine Ahnung, Elefant schiebt gerade einen Feuerwehrwagen über die Straße oder so. Und dann willst du natürlich Snap, Snap direkt.
Ein Feuerwehrwagen über die Straße? Wo war das denn?
Ja, hat lange so lang gedauert, hab ich nicht fotografieren können. Ich find das schon ganz geschmeidig, dass man mal so eben so Snap aus dem Log-Screen, Finger hoch und dann startet. Das ist ja dann mit diesem neuen Touch-Undy kann man das ja auch nicht mehr benutzen, oder? Aber kann man nicht einfach oben den Schalter drücken und dann geht er auch in den Uhrzeitanzeige?
Ja, natürlich, aber der Schalter ist ja nicht mehr oben, sondern nach drüben gewandert.
Achso, und da findet man ihn nicht mehr, oder?
Ja, also ich hab immer das Problem, dass wenn ich diesen Schalter drücken will...
Laut und leise gleichzeitig drückst...
.dass ich zum Gegenhalten natürlich auf laut und leise bin. Und dann muss man dreimal umgreifen. Dann ist jetzt natürlich in diesem Cover dieses Loch drin für diesen Ton aus und an. Und wenn man den mit dem Daumen erreicht hat, dann kann man den in Ruhe drücken, aber das ist alles irgendwie, nee, nee, dann lieber mit dem Fingernagel drücken unten.
Dieses iPhone 6 ist wirklich das peinlichste Gerät, was Apple in dieser ganzen iPhone-Saga jemals produziert hat.
Man kann ja auch jetzt sagen, es ist langsam ein Peak-Smartphone, weil den fällt ja auch nichts mehr ein. Deswegen kommt ja auch so ein Scheiß wie Touch 3D und so. Weil es braucht wirklich niemand. Also ich kenne jetzt noch keinen, der irgendwie gesagt hat, nee, wieso ist das doch ganz cool.
Also Cursor schieben finde ich schon cool. Ansonsten brauche ich es jetzt auch nicht. Also ab und zu fällt mir mal ein, dass es das gibt, aber...
Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich da relativ wenig Verständnis dafür, dass wenn die Kamera-App ein Mikrofon braucht, was bitte hat das mit meinem Kopfhörer zu tun? Ja, das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob der Geschirrspüler ausgeht, wenn du deine Waschmaschine beladen willst. Ja, das ist ja auch am Wasser angeschlossen.
Jaja, naja, du hast natürlich recht. Das geht einfach nicht.
Ich meine, die haben mal den geilen iPod in dieses Telefon eingebaut. Es hat Jahre gedauert, bis das irgendwie halbwegs bedienbar wird. Und jetzt wird das irgendwie immer schlimmer. Also diese iPod 5G war einfach mal ein Traum-Device. Ich überleg schon, ob ich da irgendwie nochmal...
Das stimmt, der iPod 5G war der letzte gute iPod.
Das war einfach ein Hammergerät. Allein das Audio-Scrolling, da geht ja bis heute nichts.
Ja, der iPod 6. Generation, der hat ja so eine fiese Latenz in diesem Scrollwheel drin, sodass es eigentlich nicht mehr zu benutzen ist. Wo der iPhone 5. Generation halt noch wirklich snappy reagiert, ist diese iPhone 6.
Du meinst den, den sie dann Classic genannt haben?
Ja, ja, genau. Der ist ganz gruselig. Also, warum auch immer.
Warum auch immer. Ja, sehr viel mehr kann ich nicht zu sagen zu dem Device.
Das war jetzt dein Problem, das...
Na, das ist, sagen wir mal, das einzige...
Ist ja ein Software-Problem aber eigentlich, oder?
Ist ein reines Software-Problem.
Das hatte Sechser ja auch.
Also, ich meine, ich kann ja verstehen, dass wenn sie das Mikrofon anschalten, dass der interne Lautsprecher da ein Problem ist. Du willst halt nicht das, was aus dem Lautsprecher quäkt, während du eine Aufnahme deiner Umgebung machst. Dann steht das ja im Konflikt. Aber dieses Telefon weiß, dass ich da einen Kopfhörer drin habe. Es weiß das einfach. Wenn ich es rausziehe, stoppt er ja auch. Also weiße das. Und hat dafür eine eigene Lautstärkeregelung und alles.
Er macht auch den Lautsprecher aus, wenn man das reinsteckt.
Schaltet um dann, ja.
Also weiß, dass da was drin ist.
Er weiß alles. Aber keine Ahnung, ob sie der Meinung sind. Na ja, das muss ja kein Kopfhörer sein. Das kann ja auch eine Boombox sein, die da irgendwie ist.
So what?
Dann ist es vielleicht auch genau das, was ich aufnehmen will. Die Situation im Raum, während ich hier von meinem Telefon Musik abspiele und alle sind happy und die Situation, die muss ich jetzt mal fotografieren. Und du schaltest die scheiß Kamera ab und die Musik ist aus. Bitte!
Schreib dir Timme in der Mail.
Also wirklich, ich meine, ich weiß ja, dass sie das nur machen, um ihre Energiebilanz hinzubekommen in Cupertino. Deswegen, wegen solcher Sachen, können sie da stehen und sagen, alle unsere Stores laufen auf regenerativer Energie. Weil so was Steve Jobs da im Grab rotieren lässt und es werden einfach die Megawatts im Inneren des Rings generiert. Das ist doch eigentlich das ganze Ding.
Wie ist denn das, diese komischen Live-Fotos, die nehmen doch gar kein Audio auf eigentlich, ne?
Ich denke schon oder nicht? Warum sollten sie sonst das Mikrofon, also warum sollten sie das Audio ausschalten?
Also ich hab da noch nie Ton gehört bei diesen Dingern.
Aber wenn ich gar kein Live-Foto mache, warum machen sie das dann trotzdem?
Wenn sie noch nicht mal Ton machen, dann gibt es ja noch nicht mal eine gute Erklärung dafür.
Vielleicht hast du es noch einfach nie gesehen, weil ich immer auf Angenommen hatte, das braucht ja kein Mensch. Aber Video ist das neue Foto.
Also neben Audio auf heißt es hier im schlauen Chat.
Der ist immer schlau.
Hier kommt noch die Frage, wie gut das Mikrofon beim SE ist. Keine Ahnung. Also ich würde das Mikrofon für Podcasting nur in Ausnahmefällen nehmen. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass in dem Technologiebereich irgendetwas nennenswertes sich entwickelt hat.
Hier schreibt einer, wenn man die Fotos auf dem Rechner abspielt, haben sie Audio, aber nicht auf dem Phone selber. Minano. Okay, Live-Foto mit Audio, Gerät muss auf Laut sein. Na gut, dann halt. Ich hab's immer leise. Also sehr selten ist der Schieber bei mir nicht auf Rot. Aber das ist...
Was heißt Gerät muss auf Laut sein? Live-Foto mit Audio, Gerät muss auf Laut sein.
Der Mute-Schieber darf nicht auf Rot sein. Dann gibt's kein Audio.
Wie? Ach, keine Wiedergabe? Oder keine Aufnahme?
Nein, dann gibt's keine Wiedergabe.
Ach so, ja okay. Soll er ja auch nicht. Wie gesagt, mir interessiert Foto nicht so. Mich interessiert einfach Audio-Wiedergabe. Und das ist einfach mal Fail. Also das können sie ja auch nochmal fixen. Genug zum iPhone SE. Wollen wir über Macs reden?
Nenn noch mal kurz den Preis, damit man das nochmal wieder in seine Rübe reinkriegt. Also... Das ist jetzt die 64 GB Version, ne?
Ja.
Es gibt auch nur 16 und 64, die 32 gibt's auch nicht. Oder war das wieder der gleiche Stunt?
Es gibt auch kein 128, ne?
Es gibt kein 128er. Und wenn man sich das so in der 64 GB Version klickt, dann kommst du so brutto bei 589 raus.
Ich kann das schon absegnab machen.
Schon ordentlich billiger als so ein 6S, oder? Also so ein 6S mit 64 GB kostet 860 oder so, ne? Oder 840?
Deutlich billiger. Also ein 64 GB Phone hat bis vor kurzem noch mindestens 200 Euro mehr gekostet, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett vertue. So, dann hab ich das noch elegant mit einer Vertragsverlängerung kombiniert und hab jetzt mal ein Telefon-Setup, was mich jetzt gar nicht so viel gekostet hat, mit ordentlich Daten. Jetzt kann es langsam mal losgehen im 21. Jahrhundert.
Und das ist immer dann ein peak-doller Gerät, wenn die Nerds nicht mehr das Rechts-Unten-Modell kaufen müssen. Dann ist es irgendwie vorbei mit.
Das ist ja das Rechts-Unten-Modell. Sorry, ich kann diese Frühstückstablets einfach nicht ernst nehmen.
Also ich kann den Suchtfaktor großes Display schon auch verstehen, aber von der Bedienung her ist es halt eine Katastrophe.
Also immer wenn ich auf 6 Plus Hardware teste für irgendwas, dann denke ich mir so, eigentlich kann ich ja gleich das iPad Mini benutzen.
Bitte, guck dir das Ding doch mal an, wie das schon aussieht.
Was denn?
Diese abgelutschten Ränder und das sieht einfach billig aus. Das ist einfach, sorry, da geht keine Emotion. Ich kriege da einfach nicht mal, da schwitzt keine Pore. Null. Die Sexiness von diesem Gerät ist nicht existent. Ganz im Gegenteil. Da sind dann auch noch diese Streifen auf dem Rücken und dann diese Wackelkamera. Ich meine, was erlaube... Was erlaube Eif?
Du, der hat gerade zu tun, der muss ein Auto designen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Oder neue Armbänder für die Uhr.
Hast du gesehen, was Johnny Eif für ein Auto fährt?
Nee, was denn?
Oder in was für einem Auto er sich fahren lässt?
Das ist doch bestimmt was Englisches irgendwie.
Er lässt sich fahren. Ist das so ein Spaß? Ich würde mich eigentlich auch fahren lassen. Ich meine, näher kommst du heutzutage an autonomes Auto dich ran.
Als fahren lassen?
Du setzt dich halt rein, liest eine Zeitung und sagst, fahr mich zu Apple und dann fährt dich halt das Ding zu Apple. Problem ist, du bist halt nicht alleine, aber es ist halt aus deiner Perspektive relativ autonom und ziemlich sicher.
Genau so.
Johnny, lass schon mal den Wagen vorfahren.
Ach, wenn ich genug Asche für einen Chauffeur hätte, ich kann das verstehen.
Ich muss jetzt nur kurz noch mal gucken, wie dieses Modell heißt. Und zwar fährt er einen Bentley.
Ja, Bentley, war ja klar.
Und zwar, er hat so einen ganz komischen Namen, irgendetwas mit M. Bentley... Bentley...
M, nicht W? Diese Brass oder Phrase? Oder ist das ein Rolls Royce?
Ich blicke da auch mal nicht durch. Warte mal, ich guck mal hier. Bentley...
Mulsanne schreibt einer?
Ja, genau, das war's. Mulsanne, oder so ähnlich zumindest.
Ist das ein aktuelles Auto oder so ein weißes Ding?
Das ist so das aktuelle Teil, was du da kaufen kannst. Also vielleicht nicht das einzige, aber... Und ich finde ja, so diese Optik, das ist ja nichts, sondern die 2009-Variante. Also ich muss sagen, der Bentley Mulsanne, von 1985, den finde ich mal ziemlich schick. Wobei, ich muss sagen... Ja, Bentley ist immer so Panzer. Aber das ist ja auch Rolls Royce. Die haben ja so eine unfassbare, gedrungene Stabilität. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das genau sagen soll.
Die sind wie so ein englisches Landschlösschen. So ein Landgutschlösschen. So sehen die halt aus.
Es geht einfach optisch überhaupt gar nicht, das Auto.
Wie meinst du mit dem Kühler und so?
Der geht noch einigermaßen, wobei es auch schon ein ganz schöner Drum ist. Aber das Ding da, das ist einfach so hässlich vorne. So runden Leuchten da, das geht überhaupt nicht. Sieht aus wie eine Schrankwand vorne.
Aber eine 3D-gedruckte Schrankwand.
Also ich hab da auch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. So kann man in diesen Scheiß-Slack eigentlich keine Fotos reindrängen.
Vielleicht nicht in die Eingabeleiste, sondern einfach oben rein.
Warum nicht in die Eingabeleiste oder sonst?
Direkt rein in den Scroll-Bereich.
Das Problem ist, dass es halt nur so ein blöder Web-Up ist.
Ach und die kann das alles nicht. Ja, nee, ist nicht schick das Auto. Aber ich find Engländer und Autos, obwohl na doch, die haben ja erst Martin und so.
Ja, also nicht schick ist schon so ein bisschen vermessen. Ähm, das ist nicht.
Das kann ja alles sein, aber von außen schön ist es nicht. Geht gar nicht vorne. Hinten ist alles einigermaßen okay, aber die Front mit diesen Scheinwerfern ist total verkackt.
Ja, auch hier mit diesem Schuss.
Das Auto sieht von vorne aus wie eine japanische Version von ET.
Und ehrlich gesagt, von hinten geht es auch gar nicht.
Nee, also wie dieser...
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man sich so ein Auto holt. Außer Optik ist einem egal. Und ich weiß nicht, bei dem Johnny Ive vielleicht, weißt du... Man sagt ja, dass so Chefköche von so 3-Sterne-Restaurants, die gehen nach Arbeit, gehen halt in die Currybude und holen sich Pommes und Currywurst, weil sie können dieses feine Zeug nicht mehr sehen. Und vielleicht geht es ihnen ja auch so.
Du hast das Auto gerade als Currywurst mit Pommes bezeichnet.
Optisch auf jeden Fall. Also wirklich, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, das ist so unteres amerikanisches Niveau irgendwie. Aber es soll edel aussehen, ne?
Ja, da kann ja auch alles toll drin sein und Motor und weiß nicht, dass ich bestimmt nur wieder drei Tonnen das Auto...
Aber diese Kindchenschema Frontleuchten, also ich bitte dich.
Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, ob dieses Auto auf diesem Foto...
Gut rüberkommt? Nein, tut's nicht.
Ja, also ob das dann wirklich so in echt genauso wirkt, ne? Aber so... So von innen ist das auf jeden Fall mal alles jetzt nicht unbedingt komplett scheiße, ne? Aber es ist halt auch ein... Es ist halt auch so ein... Es ist halt auch so ein Dinosaurier-Verbrenner, ne?
Und es ist auch eine aussterbende Art, so eine Monster-Autos.
Ja, aber das ist vielleicht genau das, was du vermitteln willst, wenn du so ein Auto hast, weißt du, so... Ich kann mir die aussterbende Art leisten.
Nee, du vermittelst... Du bist die aussterbende Art.
Na ja, ich denke... Ja, also für mich ist das auch nichts. Dieses... Ich hab ja wirklich eine Menge übrig für englische Autos. Und sicherlich ist an diesen Luxus-Autos irgendwas noch mal dran, wo man sagen kann, ist prima. Vor allem, wenn man hinten sitzt. Aber trau mich jetzt auch nicht so um. Was würdet ihr denn sagen, sind denn die schicksten britischen Autos?
Na, diese Aston Martins?
Momentan ist schwierig. Ich fand ja den Mini immer sehr geil. Bis er dann von BMW gekauft wurde. Und jetzt halt aussieht, wie in der zu groß geradenen Almhütte. Ja, ach krass.
Also mein Lieblingsauto früher war immer ein Jaguar Daimler Double Six. Aber nur die, so, das ist so 70er oder früher 80er, vielleicht noch gerade so. Mit, glaube ich, aber auch auf jeden Fall den runden Scheinwerfern, weil die kamen dann auch so mit eckigen Scheinwerfern, die waren es dann schon nicht mehr. Und dann war es dann aber auch schon vorbei. Der heißt Daimler Double Six. Bei der 12 Zylinder und so.
Also Autos, das ist auch etwas, worüber ich mich jetzt, also zumindest das Aussehen von Autos, ist etwas, was bei mir irgendwie auch nichts triggert. Also das ist mir dann auch relativ egal.
Bin es so.
Genau, Daimler Souverän, das könnte es auch sein. Aber der ist so alt, eine Stufe neuer bitte. Scroll mal ganz nach unten. Da gibt es ja die Nachfolge-Modelle bei Wikipedia dann, oder?
Das ist ja jetzt hier ganz konkret. Oder meinst du einfach den XJ?
Nee, nee, bloß nicht. Das ist alles viel zu neu. Scroll mal ganz nach unten. Da ist doch immer so eine, was dann als Nachfolge-Modell kam. Oder?
Das bezieht sich ja jetzt hier nur wirklich auf dieses eine Modell. Warte mal, ich hab ja hier gerade noch versucht, mal woanders zu schauen. Aber irgendwie kann es sein, dass das ein bisschen anders heißt.
Nee, Daimler Double Six, ganz sicher.
Double Six.
Schreib mal, da ist er schon, guck mal. Kommst du da bei dem Gleichen raus? Ja, guck, der da. Der sieht doch schick aus da, oder? Das fand ich immer schick. Wo müssen die aussehen?
Ja, da hast du recht.
Das war doch schnittig irgendwie, trotz dem Luxus, irgendwie so ein bisschen vorne nach unten, so wie sich das von Jaguar gehört, finde ich. Das sind runde Scheinwerfer, weil später haben die dann eckige draus gemacht. Warum auch immer? Weil diese runden Scheinwerfer machen ja die Kofferraumhaube auch so ein bisschen, wird die angerundet. Nachdem das eckige Scheinwerfer waren, sind diese Rundungen in die Motorhaube verschwunden. Das ging gar nicht. Die gibt es auch noch mit, da ist ja jetzt der kühler Hochkante und dann gibt es auch noch Vertikal.
Aber es stimmt schon, das hat schon sowas von gediegener Bösewicht in einem 70er Jahre Film, wo zu viel geraucht wird.
Ich bin einmal in so einem Ding mitgefahren und es war, die Beschleunigung war wirklich ordentlich, also so ein Zwölfzylinder gibt schon echt was her und du merkst überhaupt von dem Motor nichts. Also er läuft so ruhig, das ist schon erstaunlich.
Ja, das ist sicherlich bei diesem Bentley Mulsanne auch genauso, ne?
Ne, da ist bestimmt eine Rowena V8 drin.
Der Name geht auch schon gar nicht.
Was hat der denn für ein Motor? Zeig doch mal, wenn wir schon mal jetzt hier die Autostunde machen, dann können wir ja noch mal kurz den Motor gucken. So, V8 BiTurbo, da ist überhaupt gar nichts ruhig. Hubraum 6,7 Liter.
Du, also von großen Hubräumen geht man auch schon lange weg. Die Zeiten, dass man 12 Zylinder brauchte, um die Motorruhe herzustellen, die sind schon lange vorbei.
Nee, das ist richtig, weil der ruhigste Motor, den es gibt, weil der muss sich nicht selber ausgleichen, ist der 6-Zylinder-Reihe. Und ein V12 ist ja nichts weiter als zwei 6-Zylinder, sozusagen, nebeneinander geklebt. Und das ist Laufruhe-Deluxe. Das ist so so, beim 6-Zylinder muss man irgendwie, da sind die Kolben so und die Anordnung, dass halt man eben keine Ausgleichsgewichte braucht. Das nennt sich die innere... Ruhe? Ja, nee, Ruhe nicht, aber... Man braucht sozusagen keine Gegengewichte, um diese Hin- und Herbewegung auszugleichen, damit das der Motor nicht eiert. Ich habe jetzt den Fachbegriff vergessen, aber beim 6-Zylinder ist das sozusagen, braucht man das nicht, weil die sich alle selbst ausgleichen. Und deswegen ist ein 6-Zylinder was richtig Schickes.
Ja, aber ist irgendwie alles vorbei. Das ganze Sprit verbrennen, das ist irgendwie alles bekloppt. Ich finde, man braucht das alles.
Allerdings.
Damit wären wir jetzt bei...
Bei Tesla, oder?
Bei der Superübergang. Aber ich glaube, du hattest einen Grund, warum du von Johnny Ive irgendwie unserem Auto erzählen wolltest.
Ja, ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, warum.
Dass er jetzt nicht mehr ordentlich designt, zum Beispiel.
Ah ja, richtig, genau, Design, Auto. Ich meine, die Frage ist natürlich, was designen sie jetzt? Wenn man jetzt mal wirklich annimmt, dass Apple halt irgendwie ein Auto baut, ist das jetzt der Bentley-Moussan, von dem er sich da...
Vielleicht hat er auch den Wagen extra, deswegen, weil er genau weiß, so wird ein Apple-Auto nicht aussehen, damit er sich sozusagen nicht ablenken lässt, so wie Grafiker halt in den Graumodus schalten, wenn sie arbeiten, damit sie von den Farben nicht abgelenkt werden und weiß schon. Vielleicht ist das sein Graumodus. 2,6 Tonnen.
Es gab jetzt verschiedene Berichte, wie das immer so ist, also Gerüchteküche. Oder anders ausgedrückt, nichts genaues weiß man nicht, also weder weiß man, ob sie überhaupt an einem Auto arbeiten, und wenn ja, an was bei einem Auto.
Dass sie an einem arbeiten, ist glaube ich relativ sicher.
Ja, sie arbeiten irgendwie an irgendwas. Und trotzdem weiß halt keiner eigentlich, woran sie eigentlich jetzt genau arbeiten. Und ich fand es jetzt ganz belustigend, dass jetzt auch, was war das? War das dieser FAZ-Bericht, der gesagt hat, Apple hätte ein Team sogar in Berlin.
Also mir ist das neu, aber das kann natürlich sein, dass das in irgendeinem Bericht stand.
Ich hab das auch gelesen, aber es ist halt auch nur ein Bericht, aber ja.
Kann stimmen, kann nicht stimmen. Würde mich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so überraschen, wenn sie jetzt in Deutschland Leute ranholen, die vielleicht Bock haben, für Apple ein bisschen zu denken, aber nicht unbedingt Bock haben, deswegen gleich in Kalifornien rumzusitzen.
Ja, und da stand ja auch da, dass die halt auch die deutschen Regularien und so sich mit beschäftigen müssen, weil wenn die das Auto natürlich auch hier verkaufen wollen, muss das ja auch hier zugelassen werden und so weiter. Und ich glaube, Auto bringt man halt vielleicht noch weniger schnell auf den Markt, wie ein Telefon oder ein Computer, sondern du musst ja TÜV und Zeug und das muss alles stimmen und Gesetze und so und das muss alles stehen, wenn es dann mal so weit ist.
Naja, aber ich habe auch die Meinung gehört, dass so ein Auto, wenn du keinen Verbrennungsmotor baust, ist so ein Auto ja auch kein großes Problem mehr. Zumindest kannst du fast alles, was in dem Auto drin ist, bei Zulieferern einkaufen. Und Bosch hat wohl eine fast Monopolstellung, was Zulieferer anbelangt. Und dann wäre es nicht ganz sinnlos, in Deutschland eine Dependance zu haben, um mit Bosch sprechen zu können. Zumindest dann, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man einen Großteil dessen, was man da in dieses Auto baut, sich von Bosch bauen lässt. Also es klingt völlig...
Klingt vollkommen nachvollziehbar. Auch in so einem Tesla ist glaube ich zu 60% irgendwie Bosch.
Ich glaube Elon Musk sagte sogar so was mal explizit, dass das Auto bauen nicht mehr so schwierig ist, wenn man keinen Verbrennungsmotor braucht.
Genau.
Das war das Gleiche mit den Telefonen auch. Nachdem dann die ganzen Baseband-Prozessoren, also Nokia hat die ja noch selber gemacht, und irgendwann war das so Standard und kamen wir auch in den cheapesten, in den billigsten Telefonen. In El Chipo. Genau, Bingo. Hat Apple einfach auch gesagt, wir kaufen das alles ein, stopfen das da rein, machen unser eigenes Platinchen und fertig.
Das finde ich sowieso ganz interessant in dieser ganzen Debatte. Wenn man sich mal anschaut, was ist eigentlich die Kompetenz Deutschlands und speziell was ist die Kompetenz deutscher Automobilunternehmen, also der großen Konzerne in diesem ganzen Spiel. Was können die? Okay, die schneidern das Fahrzeug an eine Kundschaft zu. Meinen sie einen Blick zu haben? Haben sie vielleicht auch. Für große Teile ist das bestimmt so. Aber man hat auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die eigentlich alle gleich aussehen. Und kaum was taugt für einen. Okay, das hängt immer von dem eigenen Nutzerprofil an. Aber was bringen sie jetzt technisch selber mit ein?
Na die Motoren.
Vor allem die Motoren. Alles andere ist eigentlich weitgehend Zuliefer. Du hast auch schon Karosserie, Zulieferer, Bauer.
Ja gut, aber die machen das Design halt selbst.
Na ja, beim Tesla Roadster hatten sie die Karosserie tatsächlich von Lotus eingekauft.
Das zählt aber auch nicht.
Klar, aber allein die Möglichkeit so etwas zu tun, zu sagen, ich geh zu einem Autoersteller und sag, ich kauf euch eure Karosserie ab.
Du meinst, das Schwerste, was die Autonindustrie macht, nämlich der Motor ist jetzt weggefallen, weil den kauft man jetzt ein und fertig.
Genau, bei meinem Motor, da steckt wirklich hunderte Jahre, also Jahrzehnte wollte ich eigentlich sagen, viele Jahrzehnte Erfahrung drin, mit wie man das alles macht, damit da nicht so viel von diesem Saft aus der Erde reingekippt werden muss und das Ding bewegt sich vorwärts.
Genau, wenn du es verkackst, dann musst du deine Testergebnisse fälschen, weil du dann so viel Energie reingesteckt hast in das Projekt, dass du nicht mehr zurück kannst, also schon klar.
Ja klar, aber da hängt ja eine Menge dran. Diese ganzen Schmierstoffe, diese ganzen aneinander schabenden Metallteile, Dichtringe, der ganze Dreck und Schmand, der in so einem Verbrennungsmotor mit drin ist. Dafür brauchst du halt dieses spezifische Wissen. Als ich irgendwie neulich mal, ich hatte bei meinem Auto so einen Leistungsabfall, ich bin wahnsinnig geworden. Und in die erste Werkstatt rein und die haben irgendwelche Mutmaßungen gemacht und irgendwas getauscht. Das war es nicht. Und die zweite rein. Und die haben auch nur mit den Schultern gezuckt. Irgendwann dann mal zur VW gebracht, weil ich da noch im Ausland war. Und dann war ich wieder hier und dann nach einem halben Jahr da, mal versucht irgendwie rauszufinden. Das Ding hat halt einfach eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit einfach nicht mehr erreicht. Nach einer halben Stunde hat er einfach aufgehört, Lastung zu bringen und ich durfte dann auf der Autobahn mit einem Anhänger irgendwie mit 30 Stunden Kilometer den Berg hochfahren. Zum VW-Händler gegangen, die haben sich das angeschaut. So, ja, wir haben da in die Datenbank geguckt und so. Alles klar, wir wissen genau, was es ist. Haben wir ausgetauscht. Hier kostet nur teuer Geld und so. Ich setz mich ins Auto, fahr in eine halbe Stunde. Gleiche Probleme wie immer. Ich ruf die da an und sag mal, Leute, tickt ihr noch richtig irgendwie? Das kann ja euer Ernst sein. Da merkt man schon so richtig, wie sie so langsam und so eingeknickt sind. Und damit haben sie irgendwie nicht gerechnet. Sie waren sich so sicher, weil die Datenbank hat ja gesagt, das wäre ja alles richtig. Dann sind wir nochmal in den Media Strays gegangen. Irgendwann haben sie dann festgestellt, dass an diesem einen Motor dann auch irgendwo noch mal so eine kleine Metallachse ist, die da irgendwo rausguckt, die in diesen ganzen komplexen Apparat von Verdichtung, Luftdrucken, die sich da anpassen, je nachdem, welche Temperatur du irgendwo hast. Also diese ganze mega komplexe Gemengelage von Drücken und Temperaturen und welchen Spritdruck du wo ansetzen musst, damit dieses Auto einfach fährt. Das kannten die halt alle gar nicht mehr, obwohl sie mittlerweile mit Digitalequipment und Analyse- und Support-Datenbank ohne Ende ausgestattet sind. Konnten sie einfach nicht herausfinden, warum dieses Auto nach einer halben Stunde nicht schnell fährt. Also wirklich hane Büchen.
Warum aber erst nach einer halben Stunde nicht?
Das hat was mit Temperaturentwicklung, Ah, er ist warm geworden.
Und was war das jetzt, ein Einschüttel-Rädchen?
Ich krieg's gerade nicht zusammen mit dieser Stößel. Die hieß das ist irgendein komischer Stößel, der dann halt auch noch mit in diesem ganzen mechanischen Druckgebimsel irgendwie mit rumgestochen hat, um da den richtigen Mix bereitzustellen.
Und der war defekt, oder?
Der war abgenutzt. Das war dann so ein 20-Euro-Teil, was sie da irgendwie austauschen mussten, und dann lief's. Aber bis dann waren schon irgendwie 2000 Euro an Reparaturen irgendwie rein investiert worden.
Hast du es zurückbekommen?
Ja, den Großteil der letzten Reparatur ja. Meine Kleinstversuche vorher in England bei irgendwelchen Werkstätten natürlich nicht. War am Ende jetzt nicht so ein Drama für mich, aber hat mir einfach mal wieder schön gezeigt, dass die einfach diese Komplexität dieser Maschinen einfach selber schon gar nicht mehr checken. Und dann guckst du dir halt so einen Elektromotor an, ja, dann legst du Strom an und dann fährt der. Strom weg und dann fährt er halt nicht.
Ja, weitestgehend wartungsfrei, je nach Motor.
Ja, da schleift aber auch nicht Metall auf Metall. Und das ist irgendwie auf jeden Fall eine ganz andere Abteilung.
Solange du nicht einen Gleichstrommotor hast, aber das hat eigentlich nur noch die Berliner S-Bahn.
Ja, aber du kannst auf jeden Fall, du hast dann auf einmal Platz. Du kannst auch vorne was in deinen Kofferraum rein tun.
Na ja, Platz ist ja so eine Sache. Durch die Batterie und so brauchen die schon auch ganz schön viel Platz. Vielleicht besser verteilt und so. Also beim Tesla ist das ja unter dem Wagen so eine riesen Wanne. Sorgt aber für einen niedrigen Schwerpunkt, was ziemlich gut ist für ein Auto.
Ja, aber dadurch wird das Teil auch extrem schwer. Also ich meine, Modell S wiegt anderthalb Tonnen, ne? Also Modell X wiegt, glaube ich, drei Tonnen oder so.
Ja gut, aber die ganze Konkurrenz in dem Feld wiegt auch so viel.
Ja, okay, das kann natürlich sein.
Oder hat keine Reichweite.
Und die machen es halt mit anderen Sachen. Die haben dann halt ein Getriebe, Motor, eine dicke Achse nach hinten bei Heckantrieb, was da nicht alles noch drin ist, Tank.
Das ist ja auch so was bei Tesla, dass sie tatsächlich halt in der vorderen Achse einen Motor haben und in der hinteren Achse einen Motor haben und beide Motoren unabhängig voneinander steuern. Und du da deswegen halt auch ein ganz anderes Fahrverhalten hast bei dem Ding.
Also nochmal auf die Debatte, was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich für Deutschland, wenn das jetzt mit diesen Elektromotoren vorangeht? Hier wird ja immer noch so getan, als gäbe es das nicht. Ich glaube, mit Elektromobilität ist es so ein bisschen so wie mit Internet. Ja, haben wir schon mal von gehört, aber irgendwie will da keiner. Und das geht bestimmt wieder weg. Irgendwann kommt es auch und dann können wir das auch.
Wahrscheinlich denken die Elektroautos so was mit Datenautobahnen, geh weg.
Aber was ich so richtig schlimm finde ist, was sie meiner Meinung nach jetzt, das hat sich dieses Jahr wunderbar gezeigt mit dem ganzen Tesla Ding, spätestens seitdem sie diesen Autopiloten auf den Markt gebracht haben, der einfach keine Relevanz hat eigentlich für das eigentliche Fahrvergnügen. Das ist ja auch so ein deutsches Wort, was so in England postuliert wurde. Ich glaube BMW hat das mal irgendwie gebracht, Fahrvergnügen. Also ich meine, man kann auch ohne diesen Autopiloten, geht alles. Aber sie haben es gebracht. Sie haben es einfach mal per Remote-Update in diese Karre eingespielt und dann konnte der Wagen das. Und das ist so Magie. Das ist so die Magie, die du sehen willst. Ah, ein Hersteller, es gibt einen Feature und bam! Auf einmal ist es in deinem Auto. Ohne, dass du jetzt nochmal ein 3000 Euro Upgrade oder das nächste Jahr Modell kaufen musstest, wie das so im normalen Prinzip abgeht. Auf einmal aktualisiert sich dein Auto in seinen Features, so wie du das von dem Computer her kennst. Und Software-Updates bei so normalen Fahrzeugen...
Overseer!
Also erst mal musst du dafür bezahlen.
Ja, und geht auch nur mit dem Bus-Schlüssel, glaube ich.
Wenn ich jetzt meinen Turan zu VW bringe und die stellen dann halt bei einer Routineprozedur fest, dass meine Software nicht aktuell ist, dann steht da ein 65 Euro Software-Update drauf. Und wir wissen, dass es wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen Bug-Fixes war. Das heißt, ich bezahle auch noch für die Bug-Fixes. Weil warum sollten sie sonst die Software updaten?
Du bezahlst eine halbe Techniker-Stunde dafür, dass der geflucht hat und sich damit rumgeärgert hat, dass er erstens das Kabel nicht richtig gepasst hat, dass sein Windows stehen geblieben ist, dass er es dreimal neu starten musste, bis er dann die richtige Version endlich draufspielen konnte. So sieht es nämlich aus.
Ja, so sieht es wahrscheinlich aus. Genau. Aber was ich am krassesten finde, ist, dass einfach mittlerweile sogar BMW, aber auf jeden Fall Mercedes und Volkswagen ohnehin schon, haben einfach jegliches Feeling von Zukunft irgendwie komplett verloren.
Ja, die sitzen da beräsig in ihren Vorstandsesseln.
Und das muss denen doch ins Schwitzen kommen. Also da wäre ich doch in Panik, wenn man auf einmal von der deutschen Automobilindustrie nicht mehr die Wahrnehmung hat, das wäre irgendwie die Zukunft. Ob sie das jemals war, sei mal dahingestellt, aber es ist ja ganz klar, geh mal irgendwo hin auf diesen Planeten und frag mal, was die Leute mit Deutschland assoziieren. Wenn du dann die Hitler-Nummer durch hast, kommt Autos und Fußball natürlich.
Und Autobahn.
Autobahn, Fußball, Autos. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Ich war irgendwann mal in Afrika, Südausafrika, im tiefsten Busch mit einem Bus, wo wirklich du nur noch an so Hütten vorbeifährst, wo Leute mit einem Holzstamm irgendwie Weizen zerdrücken, um ihre Tagesmahlzeit anregen. Und beim nächsten Busstopp kriegst du eine Zeitung in die Hand gedrückt. Und was steht da in dieser Zeitung drin? Bayer Leverkusen, Uf Urdingen 04, 1 zu 1, Bundesliga.
In Afrika?
In Afrika, im tiefsten, aller tiefsten, sandigen, die fernab jeder Zivilisation. Aber irgendein Scheiß-Bundesligaspielergebnis stand in dieser Zeitung drin. Also so viel zum Thema Fußball, aber Autos ist definitiv die andere Wahrnehmung. Und dieser Nimbus, der wird jetzt verloren gehen, wenn die sich nicht langsamer anschauen. Und ich hab das Gefühl, sie strengen sich nicht an. Was ist eigentlich mit Mercedes? Hat eigentlich Mercedes schon mal irgendwas zum Thema Elektro gesagt, außer, ja wieso, was wollen sie denn Elektro haben? Wir doch gucken sie hier, der Fensterheber.
Na die hatten noch irgendeine, haben die nicht eine Beteiligung bei Tesla gehabt? Ziemlich hohe sogar und sind aber wieder ausgestiegen?
Das war doch nicht irgendwie.
Ja, das find ich mir jetzt auch grad nicht so sicher. Oder verwechselst du es vielleicht mit Smart, aber ich bin mir jetzt auch grad nicht so sicher.
Nee, oder ne, warte, Daimler hatte irgendwie eine Batteriebeteiligung, wollten die bei der Giga Factory mitmachen und sind ausgestiegen, irgendwas war da.
Ja, vier Prozent Tesla-Altteile hatten sie mal, haben sie im April 2015 abgegeben. Na ja, auf jeden Fall, alles, was die halt bringen, sind so Zukunftskonzepte und so, ja, hier haben wir unser Zukunftsauto und so Porsche, zugegebenermaßen sieht sehr sexy aus, ihre komische Porsche 911 E-Motor-Variante. Sieht geil aus, aber ist halt so, ja, in fünf Jahren.
Ist das ein Hybrid oder ein Panzer?
Ich glaube, die haben das gleiche Problem, was Microsoft hatte, als das mit dem ganzen Mobilkram losging. Also ich meine, Microsoft hatte den Markt mobile Devices mit Pen-Windows und wie das alles hieß, ja eigentlich schon im Sack. Aber sie hatten halt das Problem der Cannabilisierung ihres eigenen Marktes. Und so sehen, glaube ich, die deutschen Autohersteller das auch. Also ich glaube, du hast es als Entwicklungsabteilung in einem deutschen Autoherstellerunternehmen einfach super schwer, so ein Zukunftsauto zu bauen, was dann eventuell deinen eigenen Absatzmärkten irgendwie Käufern wegnimmt, der Nachbarabteilung. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Problem, dass so große Konzerne haben, dass sie ihr eigenes sich selbst ein Konkurrenzprodukt zu bauen, halt eine extrem schwere Angelegenheit ist, die dann intern auch mit ganz fiesen Methoden dann abgewürgt wird.
Das Microsoft-Problem.
Ich hatte jetzt Microsoft mal als Beispiel gebracht, aber ja, Microsoft hat garantiert dieses Problem auch gehabt.
Ja, Windows versus Office. Plattform versus Applikation, das war genau das Ding. Und die konnten alle nicht gegeneinander.
Ja, und wenn du dir anguckst, was Tesla macht...
Man ging gegeneinander, aber nicht miteinander.
Tesla hat einfach Clean Slate. Die können sich einfach hinstellen und sagen, was ist denn ein geiles Auto? Das und das und das wollen wir haben. Das bauen wir jetzt einfach alles rein. Keine Kompromisse, kein nichts. Wir fangen von Null an. Apple hat genau die gleichen Voraussetzungen. Die können auch bei Null anfangen und müssen sich nicht um irgendwelche Abteilungen kümmern, die ihre Dieselmotoren noch irgendwie schönen müssen. Mit blauem Dampf da.
Das ist das generelle Problem, dass sie diese Technologie als Konkurrenz zu ihrem etablierten System und ihren Stärken sehen, aber nicht bereit sind, das komplett einzugehen und selber ihren eigenen Markt zu kannibalisieren. BMW ist zumindest schon mal ein bisschen weiter, indem sie halt mit diesen E-Modellen es ja schon mal geschafft haben, dafür eine komplett eigene Fabrikationsstraße zu machen, ein komplett eigenes Karosserie-Konzept auch dafür zu entwickeln, richtig viel Geld in die Hand genommen haben.
Ein Serienmodell hergestellt. Wir haben ein Serienmodell hergestellt.
Das fährt einfach auf diese Straße.
Das kann man kaufen.
Aber trotzdem habe ich auch den Eindruck, dass das in ihren Vertriebsstrukturen einfach auch noch nicht so angekommen ist.
Na gut, das ist jetzt nochmal ein ganz anderes Problem.
Dann gehst du mal zu irgendeinem Händler, der erzählt dir erstmal eine halbe Stunde, was alles scheiße ist an der Elektro.
Die schreiben da gerade, dass das Autopilot-Update zweieinhalbtausend Dollar kostet.
Ja, aber das schreiben sie, ist auch richtig, weil du brauchst, glaube ich, für das Autopilot-Update brauchst du gewisse Sensoren, die müssen eingebaut werden. Aber die eigentliche Software kostet nichts. Wenn du die Sensoren hast, kannst du es einfach benutzen. Aber du musst halt, wenn du dieses Autopilot-Feature haben willst, musst du halt die entsprechenden Sensoren eingebaut haben. Deswegen musst du da zwei, zwei, fünf extra bezahlen. Aber die hatten eine Weile lang das schon eingebaut. Und wenn du das eingebaut hattest, dann hast du den Autopilot so für ein Software-Update bekommen. Das Gleiche gilt für den Insane Mode, der auch andere Hardware ist. Der heißt jetzt Ludicrous Mode. Ja, da bauen sie andere Kontakte an die Batterien ran, die eine höhere Stromstärke können, damit der Motor dann tatsächlich auch mehr Leistung ausliefern kann. Vielleicht bauen sie sogar andere Motoren ein. Deswegen kostet dieses Update, obwohl es so aussieht, als wäre es nur ein Schalter auf dem Dashboard, 10.000 Euro. Aber es ist halt wirklich andere Hardware, die sie dann verbauen.
Man kann ja bei unseren großen Autobauern, hier Daimler, BMW, Porsche, VW, Audi, wie auch immer, denken, naja, die machen ja das mit dem Autobau schon eine Weile und die haben den Markt im Griff und die wissen, wie viel Elektro-Tank-Säulen es hier schon gibt und wann der Markt reif ist. Also jetzt optimistisch gesehen. Und dass man denkt, also klar, die kommen halt raus mit fertigen Produkten, die sie da auch in irgendwelchen Hintertüren designen, wenn es dann halt mal so weit ist. Aber wenn man sich früher halt Nokia angeguckt hat, wie die das halt auch nicht geschafft haben, wobei es ja eigentlich, es war ja abzusehen so. Die dachten sich auch, ach, das wird ja nix. Ja, denke ich mir, dass die Autofirmen das auch verkacken eventuell. Wobei ich schon finde, dass das jetzt eindeutig ist, dass auf jeden Fall das Elektroauto kommt und das normale, den normalen Verbrennungsmotor ablösen wird, was vielleicht bei den Smartphones und mit dem iPhone nicht so ganz so eindeutig ist.
Je nachdem, wen du fragst, ist es nicht so eindeutig. Momentan sieht es halt so aus, dass in Deutschland Strom teuer ist. Sehr teuer. Und Benzin ist relativ billig momentan.
Ja, das ändert sich aber auch wieder.
Ja, natürlich ändert sich das auch wieder. Aber momentan ist es halt so, und es gibt da glaube ich draußen relativ viele Leute, die da einfach nicht dran glauben, dass das mit der Elektromobilität wirklich gut funktioniert. Das Ding ist halt, wenn du heute tatsächlich ernsthaft erwähnst, ein Elektroauto zu fahren und du hast keine Garage mit Stromanschluss, dann wird es auch echt schwierig. Weil guck dir mal an, wie viele Ladesäulen du so in Berlin hast. Guck dir mal an, wie viele Ladesäulen es auf der Autobahn gibt. Besonders wenn du die ganzen Tesla-Supercharger nicht benutzen kannst. Dann wird es echt extrem schwer. Aber ich glaube, das ist halt auch so ein Infrastrukturding. Deswegen, sobald die Infrastruktur einen kritischen Moment überschritten hat, dann könnte das relativ schnell gehen.
Und die Tesla-Supercharger kannst du auch benutzen. Da dürfen alle Autos tanken. Die müssen man halt nur bezahlen, doch? Weil Tesla will ja die Elektroautos vorwärts bringen. Und deswegen dürfen da alle tanken. Nur nicht for free halt.
Ja derzeit spielt natürlich Elektro noch keine Rolle. Aber ich glaube auch, das hat so ein bisschen diesen iPhone-Effekt. Am Anfang so alle so, ja ach die paar Zahlen, jetzt haben sie eine Million verkauft und who cares. Und dann geht es auf einmal so ratzefatze nach oben. Andere Länder sind da weiter. Norwegen hat ja nicht nur 25% der Neuzulassungen Elektrofahrzeuge. Aber alle diskutieren ja sogar schon das komplette Verbieten von Verbrennungsmotoren für private Fahrzeuge zumindest.
20, 25 oder so.
Oder 30.
Die zu fahren oder zu verkaufen? Zu verkaufen erstmal, oder?
Ja, dass du keine mehr kaufen kannst. Also fahren sicherlich jetzt nicht so. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele Wagen so ausscheren aus dem Markt. Wie viele Wagen der Installed Base werden rausgenommen pro Jahr. Aber ich schätze mal, wenn du so ein Verbot 5-10 Jahre in Place hast, dann hast du dann irgendwann auch für dich eine interessante Installed Base. Ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt wird es natürlich auch knifflig mit den Tankstellen, weil wenn da nicht mehr so viele Verbrenner rumfahren...
Wenn das kippt, dann ist wirklich vorbei.
Dann ist wirklich vorbei. Wobei ich sage, Trucks komplett auf Elektro, weiß ich nicht genau.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Das ist sicherlich nochmal...
Für Trucks und Busse und so kann ich mir aber auch Wasserstofftechnologie vorstellen.
Ja, da kann ich mir vor allem auch eine effizientere Ladegeschichte auf Basis von Standard-Akkus vorstellen. Also dass du wirklich quasi so vorgeladene Zugmaschinen rumstehen hast, die du da einfach nur noch austauschst und hinten wieder hinstellst zum Aufladen. Oder du schiebst halt den kompletten Akku-Pack unten rein.
Ja, da müssen sie sich halt was einfallen lassen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein extrem automatisierbarer Bereich, der ja auch vor allem noch ein viel höheres Interesse an Automatisierung hat. Also wenn du so eine vollautomatisierte Lkw-Spur hast mit autonomen Lkws, das würde enorm was bringen, weil dann musst du da nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche übermüdeten Leute da drin rum sitzen haben, die die ganze Zeit auf grüne Streifen weißer Rand blicken. Sondern die koppeln sich halt einfach alle hintereinander, fahren 5 Meter Abstand in derselben Geschwindigkeit und fertig ist die Laube. Bei mir ist es ein, wo die hin sollen. Das ist ja nun kein individueller Fahrspaß.
Was hat ihr da schon mal irgendwo gemacht auf so einer Teststrecke?
Das gibt es hier und da und so. Das braucht natürlich eine Weile, weil da auch noch mehr dran hängt, als nur die eigentliche Autobahnfahrt. Aber ich halte das für durchaus machbar, dass man irgendwann sagt, okay, es gibt jetzt hier einfach... Die innere Spur ist quasi nicht die äußerste Überholspur, sondern das ist einfach die Truckspur. Da hat einfach keiner hinzufahren. Die wird halt abgetrennt mit irgendwelchen kleinen Leuchtschnupsis da auf der Straße und dann fahren die Trucks da halt hin und fahren da irgendwie ihre 120 Stundenkilometer und fertig ist die Laube. Why not? Oder auch die rechte Spur, keine Ahnung.
Aber dieses ganze Selbstfahren, das bringt natürlich einen ganzen Berufsstand in Gefahr. Aber ich meine, gut, Kraftfahrer, Berufskraftfahrer ist ja jetzt auch nicht der Traumjob. Ich weiß nicht, es mag Leute geben, die das gerne machen. Und für die, das der Traumjob ist. Aber ich glaube, da sind viele dabei, die könnten sich auch was anderes vorstellen.
Ja, ob es für die Leute in dem Sinne Jobs gibt, die in demselben Bezahlsegment dann auch noch existieren, in ausreichender Menge, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Ja, aber das ist genauso wie die Robotisierung der Fabriken. Irgendwann früher 80er, Ende 70er, da sind halt auch relativ viele Deppal-Jobs beiraufgegangen. Das wird passieren und es wird ein großes Wehklagen der Gewerkschaften geben, aber letzten Endes ist es eigentlich für alle das Bessere.
Ja, in dem Moment, wo man halt für einen sozialen Ausgleich sorgt.
Jaja, klar.
Ja, vielleicht passiert es. Ich denke, es kann halt durchaus sein, dass wir in einer hochtechnisierten Gesellschaft, hochtechnisiert meine ich jetzt sozusagen im Vergleich, heute sind wir es nicht.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wir denken ja, wir sind hochtechnisiert, aber ich glaube, dass in 20, 30 Jahren...
Da ist noch Luft.
Da ist noch viel Luft drin.
Mehr geht immer.
Ja, mehr geht immer. Aber es kann halt auch wirklich den Punkt erreichen, wo so einfache Tätigkeiten nicht mehr in der Menge bereitgestellt werden können, wie es theoretisch dafür Nachfrage gibt. Weil das Bildungsniveau sozusagen für höhere Berufungen nicht unbedingt ausreicht. Es wäre zwar wünschenswert, mehr Fähigkeiten in diese Richtung zu entwickeln, aber es wird immer einen Teil geben, der das ebenso nicht mitmacht, wo dann eben die Automatisierung der Arbeit einfach Probleme aufwirft. Und ich denke, dass sich das letzten Endes nur über so Ideen wie Grundeinkommen etc. abfedern lässt. Dass man halt auch einfach sagt, okay, jetzt denken wir uns nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche bekloppten Jobs aus, damit jetzt so ein kritischer Teil der Gesellschaft auch noch sich betätigen kann. Sondern jetzt deckeln wir das halt einfach über ein Grundeinkommen. Das kommt uns am Ende billiger, als da komplizierte Lösungen anzustreben. Wenn man sich anschaut...
Ja, wir gleiten ab.
Wir gleiten vielleicht ab, aber ich meine, das ist auch mal ein wertvoller Blick in die Zeit. Wenn du dir anschaust, ein durchschnittlicher Agrarbetrieb kann heute mit einem Personalstamm von vier, fünf Leuten einen landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb fahren, wo du vorher 50 oder 500 Leute gebraucht hast.
Ja, für die meisten Arten von Dingen, die du anbaust. Also nicht alle. Also Weinernte gibt es zwar auch Maschinen, aber den guten Wein machst du halt doch handgeschnitten. Ja, also Erntehelfer, da gibt es immer noch Dinge, wo du halt Erntehelfer brauchst. Und für den Rest des Jahres natürlich nicht.
Ich sage nicht, es gibt, ich habe nicht gesagt, es gibt nichts mehr, wo nicht noch manuelle Tätigkeit ist. Aber du kannst halt heutzutage riesige Flächen automatisiert besamen, bepflügen, ernten. Das wird noch, während es aus der Erde gezogen wird, wird das sozusagen schon in distributionsfähige Formen und Verpackungen gebracht.
Alles geschenkt.
Ein oder zwei Leute, die das irgendwie aus der Ferne sich auf ihrem iPad anschauen, das war's. Da schwitzt keiner mehr. Und auch an der Stelle sind wir heute schon sehr weit und wir werden noch sehr viel weiterkommen.
Nee, aber um das Thema Tesla nochmal aufzubringen.
Genau, wir sollten nochmal über das Model 3 reden.
Das Model 3 wurde ja so quasi vorgestellt. Ich weiß nicht, hast du dir das angeguckt, dieses 20-Minuten-Video?
Ich hab mir das angeschaut, das ist so...
Er macht drei Jokes, dann fahren sie die Autos raus und dann war das Ding eigentlich auch schon wieder vorbei.
Aber sag mal, dieses Model X, was dazwischen war, das ist doch gerade erst mal nicht mal so richtig ein halbes Jahr her, das ist aber jetzt auch schon draußen und da.
Sie haben vor irgendwie einer Woche ungefähr jetzt endlich das Designstudio freigeschaltet. Du kannst jetzt also auf der Webseite wirklich minutiös dir deinen Model X zusammenklicken, wie du es haben willst. Das ging vorher halt nicht, da konntest du es irgendwie reservieren und ich weiß nicht, ob sie dich dann persönlich beraten haben.
Aber das ist doch dann schon ganz schön flott hintereinander, oder? Von Model X irgendwie, was ja auch später gekommen ist, als er sollte, und dann plötzlich schon ein halbes Jahr später oder nicht mal, stellen sie schon gleich das nächste Auto vor. Okay, es kommt jetzt nicht mehr vor, sondern aber...
Sie sagen, sie fangen an auszuliefern in Nordamerika Ende 2017. Also es sind noch zwei Jahre hin.
Naja, nicht ganz, anderthalb.
Und Tesla ist jetzt, was auch die Pünktlichkeit anbelangt, jetzt auch jetzt nicht so gut im Rennen immer. Also das kann schon noch so ein bisschen dauern.
Aber das macht doch nichts, wenn das sowieso das X gerade auch erst rauskommt, können sie da ja erstmal noch ordentlich verkaufen. Also finde ich jetzt auch gar nicht so schlimm, dass das irgendwie lange dauert. Und wenn das wirklich 300.000 echte Vorbestellungen sind...
Naja, ich habe auch eins vorbestellt.
Finde ich dein Ernst. Du hast 1000 Euro bezahlt dafür?
Ja, kannst du ja wieder haben, wenn du dich dagegen entscheidest. Also nach meiner Einschätzung habe ich jetzt drei Jahre mir zu überlegen, ob ich es tatsächlich haben will. Weil so lange dauert das auf jeden Fall noch. Aber warum nicht?
Was ist der Nominalpreis in Euro?
Das sind 35.000 Dollar. Einen Europreis haben sie nicht angesagt.
Und wo willst du den tanken sozusagen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich kann mir jetzt mindestens zwei Jahre noch überlegen, ob das jetzt Blödsinn war oder nicht. Und dann kann man es ja immer noch sagen, okay, ich hätte gerne meine 1000 Euro zurück. Und dann war das halt eine zinslose Anleihe an Tesla.
Aber wenn das gar kein Kaufzweig ist und man alles wiederkriegt, dann sind das natürlich auch 300.000 Fake-Bestellungen, weil dann die Hälfte davon wieder abspringt.
Ja, aber das Geld haben sie eben.
Nicht notwendigerweise, aber sie haben natürlich...
Ja, aber sie müssen ja dann auch zurückgeben.
300.000 mal 1.000 sind 300 Millionen, die sie jetzt mal eben auf dem Konto haben.
Das kriegst du jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres von der Bank.
Also Plastik, aber ja, das Geld ist auf dem Konto. Das ist auf dem Konto das Geld.
Das ist keine Anleihe vielleicht irgendwann in der Zukunft, sondern das ist transferiert worden und das können sie jetzt real in irgendwas schicken. Und mit 300 Millionen Euro oder Dollar kann man schon einiges tun.
Ja und die Angaben sind ja sehr vage.
Vor allem 300.000. Wie viele Neuzulassungen gibt es in Deutschland pro Jahr? Wir haben hier gerade die Seite offen. Im letzten Quartal 2016 wurden 791.000 Neuwagen neu zugelassen.
700.000.
Also fast 800.000. Tesla hat jetzt von einem einzigen Modell 300.000.
Ja, aber weltweit. Nicht in Deutschland, sondern weltweit.
Ja, aber es sah trotzdem was aus über die Größenordnung. Also in den USA dürfte die Zahl auch nochmal größer sein, selbstverständlich, aber das ist jetzt auch nichts. Das ist jetzt nichts. Also das sind alle Autos, alle. Ein einziges Modell ist erfolgreich, wenn du vielleicht 10.000 oder 5.000 verkaufst in so einem Quartal. Das ist ein erfolgreiches Auto. Es gibt kein einziges Auto, von dem 300.000 Stück verkauft werden.
Gibt es nicht. Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher. Es ist ja, wie gesagt, weltweit. Also wenn eine deutsche Autofirma, ich glaube schon, dass die weltweit deutlich mehr verkaufen als diese 300.000. Zumindest im Jahr.
Aber nicht von einem Modell.
Golf ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der richtige Vergleich.
Für das Modell 3? Ja, hat doch schon. Das dürfte ungefähr in der gleichen Liga sein.
Das war jetzt hier gerade mal so eins.
Hier behauptet jemand, 300.000 Fahrzeuge ist die Jahresproduktion vom VW-Werk Wolfsburg.
VW Passat 15,5 Millionen.
Innerhalb des VW-Konzerns weiß der Golf derzeit in Klammern 2012 mit nur 900.000 Einheiten jährlich die dritthöchste Produktionszahl auf, hinter dem Jahr Passat und dem Jetta.
Ja, das sind schon noch mal andere Zahlen, das ist nicht so, dass...
VW Golf 29 Millionen, dritter Platz.
Pro Jahr oder was?
VW F-Serie 35 Millionen, das ist so ein Pick-up-Ding bei den Amis.
Das Ding wird seit 1977 verkauft.
Toyota Corolla, seit 1966 37 Millionen Stück.
Das ist jetzt wirklich keine relevante Zahl.
Pro Jahr wäre dann schon entscheidender.
Aber sind halt Kaufte und keine Voraussagen über 1000 Dollar, die sich die Leute wiederholen können.
Das muss man schon mal noch relativieren. Ich fand ganz interessant, Sie geben mir bei den anderen Modellen an, wie groß der Akku ist. Das ist ja etwas, was ich eigentlich relativ interessant finde. Wie groß ist eigentlich der Akku von diesem Modell 3? Dazu gibt es aber keine Angabe. Dann habe ich mal nachgerechnet, was verbrauchen die Autos eigentlich jetzt mal? Was sie behaupten, wie weit sie kommen mit ihrem Akku und wie viel Akku sie haben. Das ist ganz interessant, weil es gibt sich ein relativ konsistentes Bild von ungefähr 16 bis etwa 20 Kilowattstunden pro 100 Kilometer Akku. Also hier das Modell S ist so bei 16. Das Modell X geht bei 18 los bis 20. Also es verbraucht wirklich deutlich mehr Strom.
Kann man das nicht auf das Gewicht umrechnen von dem Fahrzeug?
Vielleicht, ja.
Müsste ja eigentlich, oder?
Und wenn man jetzt die Zahlen bei den anderen Autos nicht ganz so einfach rauszufinden, aber ich komm jetzt bei dem BMW i3 bei auch so ungefähr auf 16. Je nachdem, was für eine Zahl man ansetzt, weil da fliegen 25 Zahlen rum und weiß nicht so genau schon allein, dass sie sich nicht drauf einigen können, wie groß der Akku ist. Und der Nissan Leaf kommt bei mir bei ungefähr 17 Kilowattstunden pro 100 Kilometer raus.
Also alle relativ ähnlich.
Ja, das ist alles relativ ähnlich.
Das kann man jetzt nochmal aufs Gewicht umrechnen und dann wird man sehen, die Kleinen brauchen ein bisschen weniger und die Großen ein bisschen mehr.
Wenn man das alles so ein bisschen hin und her rechnet und so von 16, 17 ausgeht ungefähr, was der Verbrauch ist, dann und guckt auf der Seite, sie geben mir eine Reichweite von 345 km an, dann komme ich ungefähr so auf 55-60 kWh Akku, der das Modell hat.
Also so wie der das Modell erst auch hat, 60, so hatte das kleine Modell ja, oder?
Ne, 70 hatte das kleine.
Ne, mit 60 angefangen.
Also es kann sein, es kann sein, dass wir mit 60 angefangen haben. Ja, wahrscheinlich 60 eher 55 oder 50. Vielleicht auch sogar nur, je nachdem.
Ja, und der Verbrauch geht halt ein bisschen runter von dem, weil es ein bisschen leichter sein wird als ein Model S, nehme ich mal an. Naja, kann schon sein.
Das ist dann so, vor allen Dingen so 50, 55, 60 Kilowattstunden lädst du halt auch schneller, als wenn du so ein Panzer mit 90 da vollladen willst. Also insofern, also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich ein gutes Auto wird.
Ja, ist eigentlich bei Motoren an Effizienz irgendwie noch was rauszuholen oder ist das mehr oder weniger nichts mehr doll groß zu machen?
Glaube ich nicht, dass da noch viel geht.
Also das ist schon optimiert, weil Elektromotoren gibt es nun auch schon seitdem es Strom gibt. Und das haben die auch schon durchoptimiert, weil es war auch schon immer wichtig, nur nicht bei Autos zu sein.
Das ist ein bekanntes Problem.
Die Brushless-Motoren kamen oder die waren effizienter, oder? Die keine Kohlebürsten mehr hatten, sondern das andere?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Naja, du hast zumindest keine Kohlebürsten, die du verbrauchst. Also wenn da was aufeinander schleift, dann ist es ja ein Verbrauchsthing. Und da hast du Übergangswiderstände und so Zeug. Aber moderne Wechsel- oder Drehstrommotoren, die haben alle keine Bürsten mehr. Das sind Gleichstrommotoren, aber das benutzt du vielleicht noch im Gabelstab.
Es kann jetzt nicht irgendwie in einen Autohersteller kommen mit dem noch besseren Elektromotor. Also nicht in 20% springen, sondern vielleicht 1% oder so.
Oder so eine minimale Optimierung, ok, ok. Also was noch spannend dann vielleicht ist, ist halt einfach die Stromregelung an sich. Also wie mache ich aus dem Strom, der aus der Batterie kommt, möglichst verlustfrei einen Strom, den ich dem Motor gebe. Aber ich glaube auch, das ist eigentlich ein gelöstes Problem. Ich meine, die ganze Technik wird in Elektro-Loks seit Jahrzehnten verbaut. Und klar, da sind Optimierungen vorgenommen worden. Irgendwann hatten sie diese Elektro-Loks gebaut, die zwar Wechselstrom aus der Oberleitung ziehen, aber den Wechselstrom dann in Drehstrom konvertieren, um dann...
Es ist so, dass eine Diesel-Lok den Strom generiert, um...
Diesel elektrisch, ja, ja. Ja, aber auch Elektro-Loks ist es so, dass du den Wechselstrom aus der Leitung in Drehstrom umwandelst, um hinterher dann einen Drehstrom-Motor mit dem Drehstrom zu betreiben, weil der deutlich effektiver ist als ein Wechselstrom-Motor. Also, aber das ist, wie gesagt, das ist alles, das ist, glaube ich, alles bekanntes und verstandenes Gebiet. Also, Akkutechnologie weiß ich nicht genau, du musst halt viele Akkus bauen. Das ist so was, wo ich noch sagen würde, das ist mal echt spannend, was passiert eigentlich mit dem, mit Lithium vor Welt, Lithium vorkommen, wenn tatsächlich mehrere große Autobauer in die Breite gehen und Lithium brauchen. Wenn die Akkuproduktion plötzlich irgendwie um Größenordnung steigen muss, nur um den Akkubedarf von Autos zu decken. Also das finde ich ein relativ spannendes Thema.
Wie viel Lithium gibt es denn auf dieser Welt?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab da keine Zahlen zu.
Ich hab mal das Gleiche gesehen oder gehört vor vielen Jahren, wo jemand meinte, wenn alle Autos auf Elektromotoren umrüsten oder wechseln, dass die ja halt die Kupferspulen brauchen, dass dann auch Kupfer halt, nicht knapp wird, aber sich die Preise ändern.
Ja, aber ich glaube Kupfer ist was sowieso schon immer ein relativ wertvolles Metall gewesen. Es gibt ja auch diese Rechnung, wenn du die ganze transsibirische Eisenbahn als Transrapid bauen würdest, dann würden die bekannten Kupfervorräte der Welt nicht genug, um die gesamten Spulen in diesem Gleisbett zu verlegen. Naja, das besteht ja nur aus Kupfer, das Ding. Das sind ja nur Spulen. Das ist ein abgewickelter Elektromotor. Ja, total. Also diese ganze Magnetschwebetechnik ist Albert.
Ich bin aber relativ zuversichtlich, dass wir in diesem ganzen Akkubereich noch den einen oder anderen Durchbruch feiern können. Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie jung eigentlich dieser Technikbereich eigentlich ist. Da wird ja de facto erst seit 20 Jahren ordentlich geforscht. Vorher waren Akkus eigentlich nicht wirklich interessant.
Naja, als die ersten Rumschlepprechner aufkamen und plötzlich die ersten Rumschlepptelefone... Ich sage bewusst Rumschlepp, weil die ersten Geräte waren ja so.
Ja genau, aber da fing das halt an, Mitte der 90er Jahre.
Oder Mac Portable, 7 Kilo oder wie viel waren das?
Ja, das gab es dann auch schon in den 80ern. Aber die schalterten im Prinzip auch daran, dass diese Akkutechnik nicht da war. Und die Nachfrage war halt einfach, hat diesen Tipping-Point noch nicht erreicht. Den haben wir nun definitiv hinter uns. Und es wird ja an so vielen verschiedenen Akkukonzepten geforscht. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass nur Lithium-Ionen jetzt die Antwort wäre, sondern es gibt diverseste, andere, vielversprechende Dinge, die noch nicht diesen gleichen Reifegrad erreicht haben und diese gleiche industrielle Nutzbarkeit haben. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man nicht noch was anderes findet.
Also bei Akkus und so oder Batterien an sich, da könnte echt nochmal so ein Quantensprung stattfinden. Das wär's. Das würde echt viele Probleme dieser Welt lösen. mein Walkman würde endlich mal lange halten. Nee, kein Walkman. Aber was man halt alles so an Zeug irgendwie hat. Und das muss ja dann, wenn angenommen sie finden halt was, das muss ja nicht mal ein Akku sein. Wenn da eine Batterie rauskommt, die plötzlich so richtig, richtig lange hält, das wär's ja auch schon. Dann muss man halt eine neue holen.
So eine Akku oder so eine Batterie muss ja eine gewisse Energiedichte haben. Und wenn du die in dein Auto einbaust, dann ist wahrscheinlich die Energiedichte pro Masse noch entscheidender als die pro Volumen. Und du hast ja nix gewonnen, wenn du jetzt den Super-Akku baust, und der ist halt super schwer. Es gibt ja immer noch diese Verfechter von Brennstoffzellen mit Wasserstoff und so weiter, aber da hast du halt diesen ganzen Ratten- Schwanz an Problemen, der da dranhängt, wie Wasserstoff ist extrem volatil und bleibt nicht im Tank drin. Und du hast einen unglaublichen Energieaufwand, um das Zeug erst zu elektrolysieren, das dann zu komprimieren und irgendwie in den Tank zu kriegen.
Der einzige Vorteil wäre, dass man schneller tanken könnte.
Deswegen halte ich auch diese ganze Wasserstoff-Elektrolyse- Zeug für LKWs deutlich sinnvoller. Weil da brauchst du halt sehr viel Power und sie brauchst du relativ lange. Und so LKWs, die sind halt irgendwie... Die müssen ja Geld verdienen. Die sind auf der Straße, die fahren halt. Du hast da keine Ausfälle. Während so ein Auto, das steht über Nacht in der Garage...
Und dann jeder LKW auf so einem Wasserstoff-Tank reist. Ich weiß ja nicht so.
Wir werden es sehen. Was ich jetzt noch ganz spannend finde in diesem Zusammenhang, ist natürlich diese ganze Stromverteilungsproblematik und wie sehr das dann auch Hand in Hand geht, vielleicht mit Mobilfunk. Weil, wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt, wo hätte man denn gerne überall Strom? Überall. Genau. Und wo gibt es schon überall Strom? Überall. Und wo gibt es speziell überall Strom?
Genau, wo hell ist.
Überall, wo hell ist. An jeder fucking Straßenlaterne gibt es Strom.
Ja, aber das ist nicht besonders viel halt, ne? Also da dürften 220 Volt mit 16 Ampere ankommen. Weißt du, der übernacht.
Na Moment, was da ankommt, ist das eine. Was da heute ankommt, ist das eine. Was da theoretisch aber ankommt. Also der Punkt ist, wo eine Straßenlaterne ist, liegt schon ein Kabel.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich kein allzu dickes.
Nö, aber das kann man ja tauschen, aber man muss sozusagen kein komplett neues Konzept von Wegnutzung aufbringen. Diese Wegnutzung ist in dem Sinne schon fertig geplant. Und es ist auch das Ding Outlet, also da steht halt auch schon was. Das heißt, wenn du die eine Straßenlaterne und das eine Kabel ersetzt durch eine andere Straßenlaterne, die halt andere Vorrichtungen hat.
Sagst doch gleich, du baust da eine Ladesäule hin, die außerdem noch Licht macht.
Ja, und die außerdem noch Mobilfunk macht. Weil wir ja jetzt sozusagen 5G vor der Tür haben. Das ist noch nicht fertig und alles. Das wird noch ein bisschen dauern, ganz klar. Aber so war es ja auch mit LTE irgendwann mal. Dann haben sie sich trotzdem gefreut, als es dann kam. Aber 5G kommt auch. Das ist jetzt sozusagen das, woran sie gerade arbeiten. Und ich kann wenig zu den Details sagen, aber die Grundparameter von 5G sind klar. Du brauchst halt viel mehr Bandbreite auf der einen Seite, niedrige Latenz. Du willst halt einfach mehr Daten dadurch pumpen. Man will halt irgendwie ein Gigabit durch die Luft kriegen. Und mit LTE ist man jetzt so bei 150 bis 300 Megabit angekommen.
Das Gigabit musst du aber erstmal wegkriegen, davon, wo du es empfängst.
Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch an diesem Kabelweg, weil wenn man in dem Moment da ein Kabel reinlegt, kann man ja auch noch ein Glasfaserkabel reinlegen.
Und da sind wir ja berühmt hier in Deutschland für Glasfaser.
Irgendwann wird auch Deutschland das tun müssen. Auch wenn man sich noch wehrt. Aber ich finde einfach diese Idee ganz gut, dass man so eine Straßenlaterne einfach neu denkt als einen Kommunikations- und Energie-Hotspot. Das heißt, du baust in diese scheiß Laterne ein 5G-Mobilstation ein und die 5G-Technik wird auch genau auf solche Nutzungen hin gemacht. Die denken sogar darüber nach, Mobilfunk-Hotspots in Gullideckel reinzubauen. Weil die sind auch schon da, die sind schon so halbwegs erreichbar. Da kannst du sozusagen Kabel durch den Schacht direkt zum Deckel legen und der Deckel ist dann sozusagen nur noch die Antenne. Und wenn halt bei jedem Gullideckel irgendwie Mobilfunk rauskommt, dann hast du halt auch eine ganz ordentliche Coverage, ohne dass irgendwas in der Welt rumsteht, dann funkt es halt einfach von unten. Da du eben mit sehr vielen niedrigen Senderleistungen arbeiten kannst, weil die eben sehr viel dichter aufgestellt sind, ist das jetzt auch nicht so, dass dir die ganze Zeit von unten die Klöten bestrahlt werden. Nicht, dass du dann so erdoganische Schrumpelklöten am Start hast. Schöne Grüße an Herrn Böhmermann.
Ja, haben wir das jetzt auch abgehakt.
Oder? Also ich fände das irgendwie geil, diese Vision. Da kann man mal drüber nachdenken.
Nö, also das ist...
Das finde ich jetzt auf jeden Fall geiler, als diese Idee von der Telekom irgendwie unsere Heimroute irgendwie für sie da die Infrastruktur aufbaut zu haben. Ja, das hätten wir gerne, oder?
Nein, aber diese Straßenlantern-Nummer ist natürlich super offensichtlich. Also man hat jetzt Bedarf für diverse Dinge. Man hat da so ein Teil stehen, da sind Leitungen verbuddelt, die müsste man halt tauschen, aber das kann man ja auch machen. Also der Leitungsweg ist schon da, dafür gibt es Wegerechte, dafür gibt es, weiß ich nicht was.
Alles da.
Und gibt ihm.
Genau, aber es müsste sich halt dann auch was ändern, dass man eben auch Mobilfunknetz auf einmal wieder kommunaler denkt. Erinnerst du dich noch an das Beispiel, was Clemens gebracht hat?
Jaja, aber Kommunaldenken scheint ja sowieso ein schwieriges Thema zu sein.
Ja, aber doch nicht hier.
Wo hier? Ja, bei uns nicht.
Na, irgendeiner muss doch den Vordenker machen. Warum nicht wir? So, das heißt, Berlin schraubt einfach alle seine Straßenlaternen um. In jede fünfte kommt ein 5G-Hotspot rein.
Es gibt aber noch relativ viele Gaslaternen.
Die bauen sie ja eh gerade um. Und dann kommen alle zehn Lampen, baust du halt auch noch irgendwie einen Stromstecker rein. Oder meinetwegen auch in jeden Scheiß, jede Scheiß Laterne einfach einen Stecker rein. Ich meine, what's the point?
So viele Laternen gibt's jetzt nun auch wieder nicht. Also schon in jede eher.
Ja, in jede kannst du ein Lade machen, aber du musst vielleicht nicht in jede einen 5G-Hotspot haben. Also da weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie das mit dem... Also da ist auch mehr besser als weniger, aber müsste jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder sein, aber damit könnte man jetzt schon mal loslegen. Ja, und dann läuft da schön das Glasfaserkabel lang. Das Glasfaserkabel sorgt dafür, dass an diesem Hotspot eben die Daten ankommen. Und das Netz, was da halt rauskommt, heißt Berlin.
Ja, und dann gibt es natürlich, dann kommt der Deutsche wieder, aber das müssen wir ja abrechnen. Und dann dieses und das übrigens auch.
Ja, wieso denn? Dann rechnen sie es halt ab. Aber sie rechnen es halt mit dem Mobilfunkbetreiber ab. Der zahlt ihnen halt einfach Kohle dafür, dass sie diesen Zugang nutzen.
Nein, aber derjenige, der sein Auto da lädt, muss natürlich auch den Strom, den er da rausklappt, abladen.
Das ist auch heute bei Stromtankstellen auch nicht anders. Ich meine, das ist vollkommen egal.
Hast du dir mal angeguckt, wie viele Anbieter es gibt? Und was für abstruse Vorstellungen die haben. Erstens, was man für den Strom bezahlt, zweitens, wie man den bezahlt und dann auch womit und wie man sich da anmeldet.
Das sind auf jeden Fall die Leute, die als erstes an die Wand gestellt werden, wenn die Revolution kommt. Gar keine Frage.
Also das ist auch so...
Ja, ich weiß. Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass alles gut ist da draußen. Ich hab nur gesagt, es wäre möglich. Hast du auch diesen Vortrag gesehen auf dem letzten Kongress zu dem Thema Elektro, Mobilität, Infrastruktur? Ja, der erzählt dann halt auch davon, von diesem ganzen Payment-Chaos und wie furchtbar das ist. Ich war ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen entsetzt, weil dir geht's ja da sicherlich wie mir. Immer wenn wir so über neue Technologien nachdenken, dann denken wir so, ah ja, das ist jetzt so und so. Dann müsste man es ja eigentlich so machen, weil ist ja logisch.
Nee, ist nicht logisch.
Und dann guckst du dir das an, wieso der freie Markt sich dann irgendwie mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt und du denkst ja halt nur...
Jaja, so QR-Code scannen und dann SMS bekommen und äh, das ist Scheiße! Und dann denkst du, aha!
Echt Leute, wirklich. Alle entlassen. Ich glaube jetzt haben wir genug über Elektro geredet, oder? Wir sollten mehr über Macs reden.
Ich bin dran. Ich bin ja heute hier ein bisschen unter... Was bin ich? Unter...
Unter Mac-isiert.
Unter Mac-isiert, weil ich sitze hier nur mit meinem 5 Zoll iPhone, weil ich hab grad keinen MacBook Pro. Ist gar nicht so einfach so ohne dynamischen Rechner. Ne, weil der war kaputt. Und zwar, ich hab ja einen MacBook Pro von 2011. Und hab da letztens in meinem Bett gesessen und hab einen Film geguckt und hab meine Sennheiser-Kopfhörer aufgehabt mit Noise Cancellation. Und hab nicht gehört, dass die Lüfter volle Pulle drehen und das... Scheiße, wenn Apple jetzt zuhört. Ne, aber die haben schon gesagt, sie reparieren es. Jedenfalls ist das Ding ganz schön heiß gelaufen und konnte nicht richtig...
Hier hört keiner zu bei Apple.
Ich hoffe. Und wenn er zuhört, dann macht das schon ordentlich.
Na komm, red sie mal um den Kopf und den Kran ordentlich.
Am besten Folge-Rechner. Oder noch neuer. Jedenfalls wurde der irgendwie zu heiß. Und dann hat's plopp gemacht. Ne, plopp hat's gar nicht gemacht, sondern ich hatte komische Grafik-Artefakte auf dem Schirm. Konnte das dann zwar noch hinkriegen, mit irgendwie Fullscreen wegmachen und wieder hinmachen und so weiter, aber irgendwie nach dem nächsten Booten irgendwie ging nix mehr. Übrigens, ich hab auch einen Tipp. Und zwar... Hab ich... Ich weiß ja, dass es dieses Problem gibt, dass wohl die... Ich glaub, das war das Problem mit dem, dass sie kein verbleites Zinn mehr nehmen dürfen beim Löten. Und deswegen sind die Lötungen damals in dem Bereich 2011 noch nicht so gut. Inzwischen haben die das ja dann optimiert, aber damals war das so ein Problem, so das wurde schneller mal brüchig. Und anscheinend, wenn es halt zu heiß wird, das Problem hab ich. Jedenfalls wusste ich schon alles klar, irgendwie hier der AMD-Chip, der da drauf ist, also die GPU hat irgendwie verkackt. Und dann dachte ich mir, naja, ich hab ja so ein MacBook Pro, da sind ja zwei GPUs drin. Und zwar einmal der Intel-Teil, der mit auf der CPU drauf ist, HD3000 oder so heißt das Ding. Und dann halt das AMD-Ding, was sich jetzt anscheinend irgendwie selbst ausgelötet hat. dann hab ich den Rechner genommen, hab den per Transporten-Modus an meinen Desktop angeschlossen, also mit Schick FireWire 800-Kabel und hab das gemountet und bin in System Library Extensions rein und hab einfach alle AMD-Treiber weggeschoben. Und hab dann gebootet und siehe da, es geht. Weil er den AMD-Karten nicht mehr gefunden hat. Weil er nicht mehr danach gesucht hat, weil er keine Treiber hatte. Und schon konnte ich im Intel-Modus meinen Rechner benutzen, aber ganz so schick haben sie es bei Apple doch nicht gemacht. Erstens dachte er, es wäre jetzt ein externes Display, mein internes Display. Also das Internat funktioniert, aber ich konnte die Helligkeit nicht mehr einstellen und irgendwie dieses Tool, mit dem man die Grafikkarten umschalten kann, meinte ich könnte nicht umschalten, weil es ja ein externes Display wäre. Okay, alles egal, aber grundsätzlich volle Helligkeit ohne was regeln zu können, ging irgendwie. Die Fenster sahen teilweise noch so ein bisschen komisch aus von den Farben, also manche Sachen stimmten nicht so richtig, aber so grundsätzlich konnte man das Ding benutzen. Naja, jedenfalls dachte ich Scheiße, weil die Leute hatten mir gesagt, Ende Februar 2016 würde diese erweiterte Garantieabwicklung da von Apple da abgelaufen. Da haben mich ja Leute im Februar noch gemeint, ey, hier Dennis, also wenn, dann jetzt und ich immer, ja, ne, aber meine Kiste läuft ja wieder ein und da ist nichts kaputt.
Sie hatten es verlängert.
Aber sie haben es verlängert. Ich hab nachgeguckt, 31. Dezember 2016.
Genau.
Also ich, irgendwann bei Apple gewesen, hab hier meine Stromstecker getauscht, weil da gibt es ja auch so eine Tauschaktion, ne? Hab zwei Linger getauscht und hab gefragt, ob ich da einen Termin brauche oder einfach mal so kommen könnte. Ich meinte, ja, ne, musst du einen Termin machen. Hab ich mir also einen Termin gemacht. Der war gestern, bin hin, musste erst mal nach Schlange stehen, damit ich sagen kann, dass ich einen Termin hab, weil der ist ganz schön voll, der war Apple. Und dann hab ich aber gleich meinen Typ bekommen. Der meinte, ja, alles klar, wir machen jetzt erstmal hier so einen Hardware-Test. Hat dann meinen Rechner gebootet, hat alt gedrückt und dann kommen ja diese Boot-Volumes, ne? Und zwar auch die, die man über Netzwerk sieht.
Jaja, der steckt da das Netzwerkkabel ein.
Genau.
Und das da irgendwo aus dem Tisch, das Netzwerkkabel, gebootet aus dem Netzwerk und dann geht's ab.
Ja, aber warte, warte. Drückt alt, damit er die Netzwerk-Volumes sieht und dann kommen so drei, vier, dann kommen so fünf, sechs, sieben, acht. Dann plötzlich wird das alles ganz viel kleiner, weil so viele kommen, dass sie in der normalen Größe gar nicht dahin passen, sondern die werden immer kleiner, weil es so breit werden muss. Und ich könnte schwören, es waren 30 oder 40 Boot-Volumes oder so. Also das ist dann wirklich für jeden Scheiß, haben die da so ein Network-Boot-Volume für jeden Rechner oder jeden Test oder wie auch immer. Dann hab ich auch schon geguckt, das war ganz schön viel. Dann hat er erst mal so einen Standard-Test gemacht, um festzustellen, dass der Rechner okay ist. Weil sie müssen das ja checken, damit man später nicht sagen kann, ey, hier, das ging alles und jetzt hab ich es kaputt gemacht. Also hat er das erst mal alles durchgecheckt, hat sich auch den von unten und von oben angeguckt und die Tastatur und Kratzer und hier und da und war alles schick, weil mein Rechner sieht eigentlich noch ganz okay aus. Und dann hat er noch so einen anderen Test gemacht, den Grafiktest halt, und der sagte sofort, ja, kaputt und man soll irgendwie TP 785 durchlesen oder irgendwie so. Also der Genius, da wurde gleich hingewiesen, dass da gibt es irgendwas, da ist was kaputt und da gibt es aber irgendwie so ein Programm. Und dann meinte er ja alles klar, das wollt ihr sehen. Und dann hat er dann noch irgendwie lange gefummelt mit seinem internen Apple-Tool, wo er irgendwie meinen Rechner dann irgendwie da einbucht, dass der halt gefixt werden soll. Das ging irgendwie nicht, aber irgendwann hat er es dann hingekriegt und dann musste ich nochmal da auf so ein iPad unterschreiben und ich krieg jetzt ein neues Motherboard. Leider nur.
Ja, war bei mir genauso. War bei mir genauso. Bei mir war ja noch das Ding, dass ich das DVD-Laufwerk ausgebaut.
Ich auch, hab ich extra wieder eingebaut. Ich hatte ja meinen WLAN-Karte sogar getauscht. Ich hatte mir dann von dem Nachfolgemodell eingebaut. Das musste ich auch zurückbauen. Ich meine, das wäre denen eh nicht aufgefallen, aber hab ich gemacht.
Doch, das wäre denen aufgefallen.
Und ich hatte ja eine SSD drin und hab aber wieder die Originalplatte eingebaut und ein leeres El Capitan irgendwie installiert. Also ich hab da richtig gemacht und getan.
Nö, ich hab das einfach so, wie es war. Abgegeben meinte nur so, ja, hier. Und ich so, ja, schreib ich hier mit den Berichtern, dann wundern sich die Kollegen nicht und so weiter.
Aber du hast es auch weggelassen beim Abgeben, das DVD-Laufwerk.
Ja, das war alles so, wie ich es umgebaut hatte.
Okay, hätte ich ja mein Zeug vielleicht auch so lassen können.
Und dann guckte er und meinte ich so, ja, ich hab hier und so. Wie hieß dieses Pseudodrive, was man da eingebaut hat?
Willport oder Drivebay? Optibay, genau.
Optibay, da meint er, ja, Optibay. Da schreib ich mit rein, dass die Kollegen Bescheid wissen. Und dann hat das bei mir, ich hab's nachmittags abends um 5 Uhr oder so abgegeben. Und am nächsten Tag um 10 Uhr rief er mich an, ja, hier, dein Ding ist fertig.
Ich war gestern 14 Uhr da und bis heute ist nichts hier. Schon mehr als 24 Stunden.
Nee, bei mir ging das echt, also...
Naja, und ich hab den Preis gesehen, dieses Motherboard gekostet hätte angenommen, das wär 500 oder so, ne?
400?
505 Euro oder 550, irgendwie was mit zwei Fünfen auf jeden Fall. Und vorne auf jeden Fall eine Fünf. Also, und da haben schon viele gesagt, da kriegen sie aber schon zwei Lenovo X-Typ oder irgendwie so. Aber gut, ich find eigentlich 500 Euro für ein Motherboard bei Apple. Mir kam es tatsächlich günstig vor, aber wahrscheinlich bin ich schon so trainiert in teure Preise, keine Ahnung. Aber ich meine, der Rechner hat ja so, was hat er denn?
Oh, da kannst du dir drei iPad-Höllen verkaufen. Wo drei Original Apple Watch Leatherbands.
Ja, oder zweieinhalb Apple Pencils.
Meinenfalls bin ich gespannt, weil ich hatte damals auch, das war der erste Quad-Core, der rauskam. Und davon gab es irgendwie ja das kleine Modell 2 Gigahertz, glaube ich, das große Modell 2,2 Gigahertz. Und ich habe das große genommen und habe aber hier mit extra plus plus CPU geklickt 2,3 Gigahertz. Und ich hoffe ja so ein bisschen, dass sie das irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig da haben, weil das war so ein Special. Und dass sie dann die 2,3 Gigahertz von dem Nachfolge Motherboard nehmen müssen. Und da ist halt dann auch eine neuere GPU aufgelötet. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie 6750 und es gibt noch eine 6770 oder? Early 2011 15 Zoll MacBook Pro.
Also ich nehme ja immer, wenn das möglich ist, die langsamere CPU. Weil ich mir denke, dass sie...
Wenn sie tauschen müssen, du auf jeden Fall eine schnellere kriegst.
Nee, weil die das Gerät, also das Thermal Design von dem Gerät, machen sie immer für die schnellere CPU. Das heißt, dass die langsamere CPU, zumindest meine Hoffnung, dann das Gerät kühler bleibt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch unten Sinn.
Ich glaube Apple ist da mit dem Cooling und so, das ist schon alles ganz okay. Ich habe schon nachgeguckt. Ich werde mir natürlich genau angucken, was ich da für ein Motherboard bekommen habe und vergleichen, ob es besser, schlechter, weiter oder irgendwie Nachfolge ist. Jetzt wollte ich noch gleich passend dazu den nächsten Schritt erzählen, was mir aufgefallen ist. Ich habe ja meine SSD ausgebaut, damit ich denen nicht meine Daten geben muss, weil das geht ja mal gar nicht. Also ich meine, das ist ja verkryptet, aber die wollen ja booten können. Also haben sie die nicht bekommen?
Ja, aber die booten doch sowieso wieder von ihrem Netzlaufwerk.
Naja, er meinte, er braucht von dem System, was ich da so pseudo installiert habe, bräuchte der User Passwort, damit der Techniker dann halt kurz so eine Art Testboot machen kann.
Das haben sie bei mir nicht haben wollen.
Na ja, hat er mir so gesagt, habe ich denen gegeben, weil war ja eh nichts drauf. Ich habe einfach da frisch installiert. Jedenfalls diese ausgebaute SSD habe ich zu Hause an meinen Desktop angeschlossen und wollte dann mal da booten. Dann habe ich gesehen, dass das Mail-Programm sich auf meinen vier Mail-Servern nicht mehr einloggen kann, weil die Passwörter fehlen. Dann dachte ich, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß? Ich habe auch von drei Accounts, die ich in der Keychain gefunden habe, eingetragen. Aber von einem Vierten, der relativ neu eingerichtet ist, war das Passwort noch nicht mal in der Keychain und war einfach nicht mehr da. Die speichern dieses Passwort anscheinend erstens nicht mehr in der Keychain ab für Mail-Accounts und zweitens verklebt mit dem Rechner, auf dem du das ein, ja wie sagt man, einrichtest. Und wenn du das dann halt auf einem anderen Rechner bootest, dann sind die irgendwie weg, diese Passwörter.
Aber die Config war noch da.
Die Config war da, das Passwort nicht. Und wenn du da klickst, dann geht auch so ein Request da auf und das ist eben nicht das Mail-Programm, sondern das geht in den Preferences, geht irgendwie der...
Diese Accounts?
Diese Account-Dingens. Und ich hab die dann alle eingerichtet, hab dann später auf einem anderen Laptop so leiweise nochmal diese Platte gebootet und schwupp waren die Passwörter wieder weg, weil es ja wieder ein anderer Rechner ist. Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach mal mit so einer Platte irgendwie zwischen einer Hardware hin und her wandern, sondern dann sind jedes Mal deine Mail-Passwörter weg. Alle anderen Passwörter komischerweise nicht, sondern nur das.
Also bei mir war das ja so, als der Rechner eine Grätsche gemacht hat, da war ich gerade am Spielen, so unter Windows, schnelles 3D-Spiel, und dann hat es ihn halt überhitzt. Und dann war halt von einer Sekunde auf die andere, war halt dunkel. Wirklich dunkel aus. Und dann habe ich versucht, den zu booten, und dann hat er halt nicht mehr gebootet. Das einzige, was noch ging...
Er hat gebootet, aber der Progress ging so ein bisschen und plötzlich wurde das Bild grau. Und es stand, richtig?
So genau weiß ich das nicht mehr. Also Firewire Target Disk Mode ging noch.
Genau, weil das alles andere ging nicht mehr. Genau, weil das alles andere ging nicht mehr. Und spätestens, wenn er umschalten will, bleibt er stehen.
Und das Geilste war, Windows konnte man auch noch bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt booten. Und dann ist er mit einer Bluescreen abgestürzt, wo dann was von Arty-Treibern drin stand.
Ja, stimmt ja auch. Der Arty-Treiber will auf die Hardware zugreifen, die ist kaputt und dann zickt es natürlich rum. Das kann jetzt auch nichts machen. Wie gesagt, der Tipp ist, System Library Extensions und alles mit AMD vorne woanders hinschieben. Man muss es ja nicht mal löschen, dann kann man es später wieder zurückschieben, wenn der Rechner repariert ist. Und dann guck erst mal in dem Elgipo Intel-Modus. Ohne Beschleunigung, das ist wirklich richtig langsam. Besonders iTunes, da kannst du richtig sehen, wie sich das in Wellen so immer wieder aufbaut. Und es ist wirklich ganz schlimm, im Finder geht aber alles ins Hörpeln.
Nee, ich hab nur mit Target Disk Mode einmal Backup gemacht und das Ding dann da abgeworfen. Fertig.
Also. Ich bin gespannt, wann die fertig sind, wann ich es abholen kann. Weil es schon ein bisschen blöd ohne Rechner muss ich sagen.
Das war jetzt glaubwürdig.
Du hättest ja ein neues MacBook kaufen können.
Ne, ein neues MacBook wollte ich nicht. Aber was ich haben will, ist gerne vielleicht demnächst irgendwann ein neues MacBook Pro. Weil das aktuelle ist von letztes Jahr. Das aktuelle MacBook Pro ist von letztes Jahr März. Also es ist wirklich schon überfällig. Oder Mai. Also schon ziemlich lange. Und alle warten eigentlich auf ein neues. Und ich hab mich schon geärgert, dass es doch nicht sein kann, dass jetzt meins kaputt geht und wenn ich mir ein neues holen muss, dann gibt es noch nicht so richtig ein neues. Und das geht gar nicht, aber Gott sei Dank habe ich gesehen, dass wir dann doch noch reparieren. Und ich kann es jetzt noch ein bisschen aussetzen.
Jetzt wo das mit dem iPhone SE so gut funktioniert hat, könnte ich ja eigentlich auch nochmal meine Anforderungen für ein neues MacBook-Preis geben.
Du meinst, ja, mach mal.
Mach mal, ich hab ja jetzt in der Firma die IT-Abteilung, ich hab mich angeschrieben, mein Rechner ist drei Jahre alt, sie wollen ihn gerne tauschen. Ob ich 13 Zoll oder 15 Zoll will.
Nicht so viel Geld da bei Ebay, die sollen lieber mal die Gebühren senken.
Dann hab ich nur zurückgeschrieben, lass mal gut sein, das lohnt nicht. Was soll ich jetzt mit einem neuen Rechner? Der alte tut noch und die neueren Dinge sind auch nicht besser als die alten. Da ist nichts passiert.
Was machen die da mit dem alten Rechner eigentlich?
Ich glaub, der wird Loner, wie es so schön heißt. Also wenn irgendjemand was abkackt, dann kriegst du halt so ein Leihgerät.
Wir legen einfach im Regal und warten darauf, dass sie mal benutzt werden.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich gibt es dann so eine Pipeline, wo die älteren Geräte dann auch langsam rausgehen. Also keine Ahnung, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Ja, aber was wäre das MacBook Pro der nächsten Generation, was wir uns vorstellen, was es sein müsste, und was wir vermuten, was kommt?
Also ich würde gerne, dass sie den Speicher, den man einbauen lassen kann, mal verdoppeln, von 16 auf 32 GIG.
Absolut dabei.
Das wäre mal ein Pro-Feature.
Ja, 32 GIG. Ja, Bild vor Order, was auch immer.
Was macht ihr mit euren Rechnern, dass ihr so viel Speicher braucht?
Arbeit.
Benutzen.
Ja, aber mit was?
Na, allem.
Beispiele?
Safari.
Du brauchst mehr als 8 GB wegen Safari.
Ich nicht, Safari braucht das.
Echt, was ist denn gerade bei deinem Safari? Wie viel verbrauchen die gerade? Weil ich hab noch 8 GB und ich komm da noch gar nicht klar.
Also meiner ist jetzt relativ zahm mit fast 5 GB.
Safari alleine?
Ja, Safari alleine.
Und dann da 1000 Tabs offen, oder wie?
Dann sagt der Colonel Task nochmal, er will dreieinhalb haben. Also ich meine Slack mit einem Gigabyte ist dann schon relativ entspannt irgendwie.
Ok, dieses komische Internet ist Schuld eigentlich. Ja, verstehe. Ja, ich hab einfach ein anderes Brausverhalten als ihr. Also solche Seiten, die machen es auf meinem Schirm nicht lange. Und ich bin auch nicht so richtig ein Tab-Fan.
Ich schon, ich glaube, ich hab hier die Tabs noch von vor, vor, vor, vor, vor letzter Sendung offen.
Nee, das geht gar nicht. Ich hab mir so das Prinzip aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn. Wenn es nicht wichtig war, dann hab ich es vergessen. Das ist aber auch nicht schlimm.
Also es gibt immer wieder Programme, die frei drehen. Ich hab hier zum Beispiel mal Hands Off so testweise heute installiert. Der wird mir gerade mit 5 Gigabyte RAM-Bedarf angezeigt. Das scheint ja auch eher ein Bug zu sein.
Ja, schlechte Software. Apple kann einen teuren Scheiß verkaufen, weil zu viel schlechte Software ist. Das war schon immer so, oder?
Ja, Slack. Es ist schön, hier auch Slack dabei zuzusehen, wie es sozusagen im 5-Sekunden-Abstand nochmal 0,01 Gigabyte frisst. Aber es geht auch mal runter, okay. Na gut, dann Cache kann man nie genug haben. Also ich finde halt, RAM ist halt einfach mal schneller als Platte.
Mal schneller als SSD auch noch, ja.
Ja, also das kann ruhig auch alles da so zwischengehalten werden. Dafür ist RAM da. Von daher sag ich mal, viel RAM, viel gut. Also ein Computer kann gar nicht genug RAM haben. Das ist halt einfach mal der schnellste Speicher.
Aber weißt du was, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Windows früher. Also ich hatte ja noch meinen Amiga und da war alles okay. Und dann hab ich von den Windows-Jungs immer gehört, wenn du mehr RAM hast, dann wird der Rechner schneller. Und ich dachte mir mit meinem Amiga immer, hä, warum wird denn Rechner schneller, wenn man mehr RAM hat? Und ja, weil die Software so schlecht ist.
Na was heißt schlecht? Also sie greift halt auf Daten zu, die auf langsamen Speichern sind. Und auch eine SSD ist mit Vergleich zu RAM ein langsamer Speicher.
Ja, das sind ja hauptsächlich jetzt die Programme, das Problem.
Dann machst du da halt mal so ein RAW-Foto auf in deinem Foto-Editor of your choice. Und das Ding hat irgendwie 4096 mal Tralala. Und da sind allein die Dateien selber schon relativ groß. Und wenn du dann halt mit mehreren Layern irgendwie mal drauf rummalen willst, da atmet dann halt so ein Programm einfach mal mühelos ein paar Gigabyte RAM einfach mal durch.
Das mach ich jetzt auch nicht so jeden Tag.
Naja, aber wahrscheinlich machst du es halt vor allem deshalb nicht, weil es halt dann scheiße langsam ist. So, Gelegenheit macht Liebe. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Aspekt. Also ich hab einfach nichts dagegen, gegen mehr RAM.
Ja, ich versteh das schon.
Ich sehe keinen Grund, diese Zahlen zu produzieren.
Wenn ich hier schon 64 Gig höre, das ist schon eine Hautnummer. Wir würden jetzt 16 im Laptop erst mal reiben, weil ich fahre immer noch mit 8 und kam dann gut klar.
Ich will halt nicht zwoppen sehen. Also es soll halt einfach mal alles im RAM bleiben.
Also ich benutze ja den ganzen Tag über eigentlich nur Xcode. Und da ist es halt so, dass so... Also noch mehr Chores ist vielleicht übertrieben, wobei ich meine vier Chores, der parallelisiert halt schön, wenn er kompiliert. Und Speicher ist ständig da am Indizieren, wenn er diesen ganzen Index vielleicht mal am Speicher halten könnte. Das wäre irgendwie auch mal ganz nett. Und so, also ich weiß nicht, ja 64 ist jetzt übertrieben, aber wenn du dir jetzt vorstellst, du hast jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt einen neuen Rechner, der 16 Gig hat und der muss jetzt wieder drei Jahre halten, dann ist halt in drei Jahren, weil du den Speicher nicht upgraden kannst, sind halt 16 dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen dünner.
Ja, das kann sein.
Deswegen willst du, wenn du jetzt einen neuen Rechner hast, gleich mit 32 starten, damit du in drei Jahren nicht irgendwie das Gefühl hast, ich brauch jetzt aber ganz dringend einen neuen Rechner.
Ja, verstehe. Gut, aber jetzt bei den Mac Pros, was dann noch so außer Speicher? Also schnelles WLAN gibt's ja, AC irgendwie, da gibt's ja auch noch nichts Neues, richtig? USB 3 und hier USB 3C-Stecker und wie sie alle heißen, können sie ranmachen. Firewire hat sich ja erledigt, Thunderbolt gibt's wohl drei schon, oder gibt's das schon? Ich weiß gar nicht. Und WAN bringt das jetzt so deutlich viel außer ein bisschen mehr Speed, also noch irgendwelche anderen Features, außer dass man vielleicht dann 5K-Displays daran anschließen kann, oder noch größer?
Bin mir jetzt grad nicht ganz sicher, welche neuen Fähigkeiten da mitkommen. Auf jeden Fall wird Thunderbolt 3 halt über USB-C geliefert werden. Also dieser Thunderbolt-Stecker As We Know Today wird hoffentlich bald der Vergangenheit angehören, auch wenn ich mir noch nicht so sicher bin, ob jetzt USB-C denn die bessere Wahl ist. Was?
Ich halte USB-C jetzt auch nicht für so einen tollen Stecker, aber ja.
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, 10 Gigabit Ethernet wäre immer cool an so einem Rechner, aber die haben ja gar kein Ethernet mehr. Aber mit Thunderbolt 3 könnte vielleicht dann ein 10 Gigabit Ethernet Adapter kommen.
Ja, das gibt es auch glaube ich schon, aber es ist halt nur arschteuer.
Echt? Das wär ja mal was, weil irgendwie jetzt hier so 10 Gigabyte Movies durch die Gegend schieben, nur mit 100 Megabyte die Sekunde, macht auch nicht mehr wirklich Spaß.
Super Use-Case, Dennis.
Das sind meine Use-Cases. Na ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Und das schon seit 10, 20 Jahren. Nur die Zahl steigt. Aber es ist immer in einem stetigen Verhältnis zum Cable-Speed und zur Plattengröße.
Da kann ich aber Neuigkeiten berichten.
Moment, jetzt wollen wir erstmal sagen, was dieses MacBook Pro kann oder können sollte. Wenn du mich fragst, also erstmal diese Portarmut eines MacBook geht natürlich in Null.
Nee, das geht gar nicht.
Du meinst jetzt dieses Rose Gold-Ding?
Unter anderem Rose Gold, egal, es kommt ja in allen Farben mit derselben Portkonfiguration.
Wie twitterte einer so schön, wenn du zwei USB-C-Anschlüsse haben willst, dann kaufst du halt zwei, ne?
Na gut, aber ich mein, das Ding hat einfach nur zwei Ports und das geht gar nicht. Und vor allem hat das halt nur einen wirklich digitalen Port. MacBook Pro müsste meiner Meinung nach mindestens vier...
Vier was?
USB-C-Ports haben. Mindestens.
Also du meinst, du hast dann vier USB-C-Ports, von denen aber dann zwei Thunderbolt-fähig sind?
Na alle sind im Idealfall allesfähig. Ich weiß nicht, ob man überall Strom reinschieben kann, aber spricht ja auch nix dagegen, dass das alles über dieselbe wird.
Ich will meinen MagSafe behalten. Dieses Strom über USB-C, da habe ich ja noch kein gutes Gefühl bei.
Ich auch.
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur mit so einem flachen Ding, wo das nicht passieren wird.
Hatte das MacBook Pro noch Audio-in eigentlich, oder war das da wegoptimiert, oder war das nur bei den kleinen Geräten wegoptimiert?
Das hat noch Audio-in, weil du kannst halt so ein iPhone-Kopfhörer da reinstecken.
Na ja, Audio-in heißt dann Mono, ne?
Mono und...
Ach so, aber das hat nur noch diesen einen 3,5 Zoll Klinke, genau, keinen Line-in mehr.
Ja, aber das hat jetzt dieses Teil hier auch schon, und das ist jetzt irgendwie ein 2 Jahre alt oder so.
Aber analog Line-in, darüber muss man nicht reden. Also der einzige Sinn vor der Audio-Input, ja, das will man auch nicht benutzen, das ist einfach mal...
Nee, also wenn...
Also es ist okay, wenn die das da abgeschafft haben.
Das kriegst du nicht rauschfrei.
Wenn du ordentliches Audio-in haben willst, dann brauchst du sowieso ein Interface.
Genau, also oder was halt immer eine schöne Option war, war halt Optical-in, was sich leider nie durchgesetzt hat, was meiner Meinung nach vor allem daran lag, dass Apple halt nie den Mumm hatte, da mal Ardent einzubauen. Ich meine, wenn sie das mal gemacht hätten, das wäre wirklich so cool gewesen. Und das hätten sie schon vor 10 Jahren machen können. Wenn jedes MacBook serienmäßig mit einem 8-Port Audio-in-Port daher gekommen wäre, ich sagte ja, da hätten sich aber so einigen Leuten im Musikbereich irgendwie die Fußnägel umgerollt. Aber der Zug ist halt jetzt abgefahren. Weil jetzt hat Ardent nicht mehr so die Bedeutung, aber möglich wäre es gewesen.
Wie sieht es aus?
Aber man kann halt nur zusammenfassen, also alles, was ein MacBook Pro jetzt an Ports hat, das Ding hat Strom, geht mit USB-C. USB geht mit USB-C. Thunderbolt geht mit USB-C. HDMI geht mit USB-C.
Und was gibt es noch den SD-Kartenslot?
Das ist das einzige, was nicht geht mit USB-C.
Das denen würde ich gerne behalten, weil so ein Nifty Drive, das ist schon ganz praktisch.
Das wird ja bei meinem Motherboard jetzt mit repariert, weil das ging nie von Anfang an. Das war auch so ein Standardproblem. Da habe ich schon gefragt, das Teil des Motherboards. Also kriege ich jetzt auch endlich mal einen funktionierenden SD-Kartenslot.
Okay, hat's ja eh schon.
Also dieses Nifty Drive und dann packt man da so eine Micro-SD-Karte. Brauchst du mittlerweile auch nicht mehr, ne?
Es gibt mittlerweile SD-Karten direkt im MacBook Pro Größe mit Abschluss.
Hat er doch.
Ja, hab ich doch.
Nein, du hast da dieses Nifty Drive drin. Und da hast du eine SD-Karte drin. Mittlerweile gibt es aber SD-Karten, die genauso geformt sind, dass du sie in deinen MacBook Pro reinschieben kannst.
Es gibt aber verschiedene MacBooks, die eine verschiedene große Eindringtiefe haben.
Für jedes einzelne Modell kriegst du passende SD-Karten mit.
Ja, aber das Nifty Drive ist ja zu einer Micro-SD-Karte nur der Adapter. Also ich kann mir in einem halben Jahr halt die noch größere SD-Karte...
Ja, aber die anderen sind halt richtige SD-Karten, die halt...
Die halt...
Aber Jungs, wenn sie beides am Ende haben, ist das doch kein Unterschied.
Ja, eben.
Ja, aber du kriegst die halt mit voller Kapazität und ist halt viel billiger.
Und du meinst, das ist zu teuer da.
Ja, das kann man immer noch... Das war, also...
Aber bei ihm sieht's schicker aus.
Ich...
Okay, weiter. Was gibt's noch? Also, würdest du beim Display irgendwas tun? Die Leute sagen hier eigentlich schon weniger Rand am Display.
Ja, aber das ist so was, wo ich sage, ey, das macht jetzt den Braten nicht fett. Klar kann man da jetzt irgendwie an jeder Seite noch einen halben Zentimeter abschnippeln.
Und wie viel Gigabyte hast du in deiner SD-Karte?
Momentan 128.
128 als Mikro? Kostet jetzt in MacBook Pro kompatibler Slot 80 Euro?
Ich glaub, da hab ich weniger bezahlt, aber das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Aber für deinen Nifty Drive hast du ja noch ein bisschen mehr bezahlt.
Ja, 25 oder 30 oder irgendwas.
Ah, es gibt auch schon 256er.
Na ja, 470 Euro.
Und im Gegensatz zu OCD ist das auch ordentlich schnell so eine SD-Karte, ne?
Ja, das finde ich auf jeden Fall mal ganz... Also ich stimme dir ja zu. Das ist ja absolut...
Nee, das ist halt insofern ganz schön. Du hast halt hier nochmal quasi so ein externes Laufwerk zu mitnehmen, wo man so Sachen drauf macht, die ruhig langsam sein können.
Die du am Flughafen dann kurz vorher rausnimmst.
Zum Beispiel, oder was weiß ich.
Okay, was haben wir noch? Trackpad, Tastatur, gibt es da noch irgendwie Verbesserungen? Also was kann man an so einem Ding noch verbessern? Die fällt mir da nicht ein.
In beiden oder nur im 13er? Nee, nee, in beiden. Tastatur können sie halt die MacBook-Tastatur einbauen.
Das fände ich aber ein Downgrade.
Ich weiß auch noch nicht, ob das so ist.
Na ja, aber ich meine sie wollen natürlich auch das Pro dünner machen. Weil sie entweder mehr Akku reinbauen oder das Ding kleiner machen oder am besten halt beides. Und meiner Meinung nach hätten sie auch einigen Grund, diese Keilform des Air anzustreben. Also nicht so einen quadratischen Klotz, weil ich finde halt vorne diese Nutzerkante, die ist dann doch nicht sehr nutzerfreundlich. Da ist das Air schon geiler.
Das ist jetzt schon ein Jammern auf hohem Niveau, oder?
Ich hab ein Air. Für mich wär das ein Downgrade. Und da kommen wir dann überhaupt zu dem Punkt, wo ich halt denke, wo mich Apple einfach enttäuschen wird. Ich hab so ein bisschen keine Hoffnung, dass sie ein 11-Zoll-Modell anbieten werden.
Naja, und dann gibt's halt noch die Frage, arm oder nicht arm?
Nicht bei einem Mac Pro.
Danach bist du auf jeden Fall arm.
Das ist der falsche Markt beim Mac Pro, wenn die das nicht machen.
Naja, beim Mac Pro nicht, aber...
Das Mac Pro ist da eher der Kandidat. Dabei sagt man 2017 erst. Meine Prognose denkt an mich und ihr könnt bei Twitter gucken, wie alt das schon ist.
Was denn 2017? Der Mac Pro-Update, meinst du? Kommt nicht dieses Jahr.
2017 kommen die ersten Rechner, wahrscheinlich mit Mac OS anstatt Mac OS X oder OS X, die einen Arm haben anstatt einen Intel. Prognostiziert vor circa zwei Jahren schon.
Naja, wenn du dir anguckst, was für eine lahme Gurke dieses Mac Book ist, da wäre so ein A10X, oder wie das Ding jetzt heißt, oder wie heißt das Teil im iPad Pro, A9X, A10, A9X. Der wäre eventuell sogar ein Upgrade zu dem, was sie da verbaut haben. Also insofern, und verbraucht dann wahrscheinlich noch weniger Strom.
Und können sie schon vielleicht noch höher taktenweise besser kühlen können und so weiter und so fort und auch mehr Strom haben?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das da mit dem Speicher ist, ob man an so einem Apple-Arm A9X irgendwie mal 16 GB Speicher ranhängen kann.
Klar können sie machen. Zwei, drei Adressleitungen mehr und dann geht das.
Na die bauen sich das halt so, wie sie es brauchen.
Und das halte ich also gerade für das MacBook für ein realistisches Szenario. Müssten das halt wahrscheinlich zur WWDC, wenn sie es machen müssten sie es wahrscheinlich zur WWDC annoucen, weil die ganzen Entwickler dürfen dann ihren Kram neu kompilieren.
Ja, aber das geht so schnell, da müssen sie nicht allzu früh annoucen. Das lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht. Weil wie gesagt, die Transition ist relativ easy. Würde ich behaupten. Außer sie kommen damit in einem ganz neuen OS wieder so Apple TV-mäßig oder ja weiß schon, in die Richtung. Aber auch dann müsste sie es gar nicht so früh machen. Wie sieht es CPU-mäßig aus? Meint das kommt ein CPU mit sechs Kern anstatt vier? Also das Default 4 ist und High End 6?
Also wie ich schon sagte, zum Kompilieren wäre es schon ganz geil. Das kann man gut parallelisieren. Ob du jetzt vier Files gleichzeitig kompilierst oder sechs Files?
Habt ihr einen sechs Kern Rechner zu Hause, das ist einfach super cool.
Das hängt einfach von Intel ab.
Obwohl, das sind ja schon so mobile CPUs. Ich weiß nicht, was die da so am Start haben euch da geschworen.
Genau, da ist halt der Punkt, wo, ich weiß nicht, ist Apple jetzt schon in dem Ding drin, wo sie mit PowerPC waren und dann gesagt haben, wir müssen jetzt auf Intel weg sein, weil das nicht mehr weitergeht? Ist die Entwicklungskurve bei ARM so steil, dass Intel nicht mehr nachkommt?
Na, das ist der Deschung, dass der PC-Markt auch so ein bisschen stagniert, ist ja auch Teil davon, weil es auch CPU-mäßig nicht mehr so wirklich vorwärts geht. Also die haben gerade 12.000 Leute entlassen. Also gibt es ja gerade diese Intel News. Also sie haben jetzt auch kapiert, dass der PC-Markt, also dass jetzt nicht mehr jedes Jahr einen neuen PC kauft, weil sie sind irgendwie alle schnell genug. Und ja, das heißt auch, die werden da weniger in Forschung investieren, um die noch schneller zu machen, weil es braucht irgendwie so richtig auch gar keiner mehr.
Was braucht keiner mehr?
Noch schnellere CPUs. Ja, die braucht man immer, aber es sind weniger Leute als vorher, die das brauchen. Der Server-Markt will das schon noch haben. Klar willst du irgendwann deine 16, 20 und sonst wie viele CPUs in deinem 1-HE-Rechner drin haben und so, der da irgendwie Zeug ausliefert. Aber zu Hause brauchst du diesen Scheiß halt nicht mehr.
Na gut, das mit dem Brauchen ist immer relativ, weil vielleicht wollen die Leute nicht unbedingt jetzt bewusst, dass das, was sie jetzt gerade haben, schneller läuft. Aber sie wollen unter Umständen etwas haben, was überhaupt erst läuft, wenn eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit da ist. Ja, sicher. Ich meine, heutzutage ist Videobearbeitung kein Thema. Das war lange Zeit mal eine vollkommene Fantasie. Auch, dass wir in Realtime irgendwie Audio in 8 Spuren hier aufnehmen und da mal eben in Windows alle durchscrabben und noch 30 Plug-Ins drauf werfen. Das erfordert einfach eine ganze Menge Performance, die die Rechner lange Zeit überhaupt nicht hatten. Am Anfang war irgendwie MIDI schon eine Pein. Und genauso werden halt in Zukunft neue Prozessoren andere Dinge ermöglichen, die heutzutage noch irgendwie so over the top gehen.
Aber müssten die nicht eigentlich schon da sein? Weil bisher waren die schon immer vorher da, diese hohen Ansprüche. Und dann kamen die passende Hardware dazu.
Die Frage ist, wer sie formuliert und wer ihnen am besten zuhört. Du könntest ja zum Beispiel auch sagen, eine Bedienung mit Siri wird irgendwann so selbstverständlich, aber sie muss halt auch ohne Internet funktionieren.
Ja, dass sie dann Siri auf seinem Rechner hat. Wenn man dann auch wieder die 32 oder 64 Gig Eventen braucht, weil die Daten manken und so weiter und so fort.
Genau. Öffne meinen Kalender, mach einen neuen Termin, morgen früh um 10 Uhr. Siri. Und dann muss das auch ratze fatze gehen. Und dann brauchst du da aber auch Burst-Mode, irgendwie Spracherkennung und Pipa-Fro. Und dann müssen dann irgendwie nochmal 30 GB von deiner SSD allein dafür abgesignet werden, immer so die aktuellen Index-Sprach-KI-Tabellen von Apple runterzuladen, damit die so halbwegs auf dem Damm sind und sich immer besser verstehen können und das Training von deiner eigenen Stimme. Das sind alles so Sachen, das schreit einfach nach mehr Performance. Natürlich haben wir dieses reine CPU-Race, das ist jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen nahe überstrapaziert worden, weil man ja auch sieht, teilweise sind es nicht unbedingt die Gewinne bei der CPU, die jetzt den größten Unterschied machen. Ich denke gerade in den letzten 10 Jahren waren einfach die signifikantesten Entwicklungsschritte, die gemacht wurden in der Gesamt-Performance, war auf der einen Seite SSD, auf der anderen Seite die Grafikkarten.
Ist ja immer noch so, wenn du dir anguckst, dass sie die neue Oculus Rift gar nicht erst für ein Mac portieren wollen, weil der Mac Pro nicht genug Performance hat, um die Oculus Rift zu treiben. Da denkst du ja dann auch so, alter.
Weil mich da ja wirklich mal interessieren würde, was die da eigentlich jetzt an Mindestanforderungen haben, was das ausschließt.
Na ja, die Grafikkarte, die da in dem Mac Pro verbaut wird, ist jetzt glaube ich auch schon zwei Jahre alt oder so.
Ja, eher länger.
Eher noch mehr.
Der Rechner ist doch schon drei Jahre alt, also ich meine...
Ja gut, aber welches Detail von diesem Gerät funktioniert auf einmal nicht, wenn diese Performance, diese maximale Bleeding-Ad...
Ich glaube, du hast ja zweimal HD, also für jedem Auge jeweils ein HD-Dingens. Und das musst du halt treiben mit, weiß ich nicht...
Aber wenn sie dann mit so einem Mac Pro nicht klarkommen, heißt das ja, dass sie da sozusagen fast keine Luft haben, dass nur der High-End gerade so eben das hinkriegt.
Du brauchst schon eine ordentliche Grafikkarte.
Ja gut, aber so wenig Headroom, finde ich ja schon ein bisschen bedenklich.
Ja, aber eine Sache, die zwei Jahre alt ist, ist noch wirklich noch ganz schön hinterher. Und die waren ja damals schon jetzt nicht top, mega, super, voll toll diese Karten.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab da keinen Überblick. Ist mir eigentlich auch egal. Wo waren wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Waren wir jetzt gerade noch bei den MacBook Pros und was da drin sein soll? Oder waren wir schon irgendwie weiter arm und so? Also, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sie sich das wirklich erlauben können, einen MacBook Pro rauszubringen, was wirklich nur mit USB-C-Schnittstellen ausgestaltet ist und wo du dann wirklich für jeden scheißdreckten Portadapter brauchst. Wäre natürlich insofern charmant, wenn du Bock drauf hast, in deiner Kiste auch mal eben 10 Ethernet-Ports oder 4 Ethernet-Ports oder 4x HDMI oder was auch immer dann möglich ist, verpassen kannst. Aber ein Stück weit ist das mit diesen Ports ja auch so eine Sache. Es geht ja nicht nur darum, wie viel man hat, sondern es geht ja auch darum, dass es einfach mal da ist und du eben nicht so einen Scheißadapter mit dir rumschleppen musst. Also allein schon, dass kein Ethernet-Port da ist, ist in gewisser Hinsicht schon so ein bisschen anstrengend.
Wenn sie den nicht weggemacht hätten, hätten sie es nicht so wirklich klein gekriegt oder wieder nur mit so komischen Tricks und so.
Genau, und jetzt, was ist denn der größte Port jetzt? Also USB und Thunderbolt haben so in etwa dieselbe Dimensionierung und der Strom auch.
HDMI ist relativ groß noch.
HDMI auch, ja.
Strom ist relativ groß. Na ja, und dann hast du noch den SD-Slot.
Aber Strom ist doch schon schmaler geworden.
Strom ist schon schmaler geworden, ja.
Das sieht man ja deutlich. Du meinst, zum ersten Entwurf. Ja, sicherlich, aber es ist halt jetzt... Kleiner geht immer. Ja, was lernen sie noch aus ihrem MacBook? Ich meine, sie wollen halt die... Sie wollen natürlich die Platine möglichst klein kriegen, damit die eben mit möglichst wenig Strom auskommt. Andererseits, wenn sie wirklich Thunderbolt da liefern, dann müssen sie natürlich auch enormen Power liefern. Muss alles miteinander verkabel sein. Also mir ist es unklar, was da die Konstraent sind, aber der Trend ist klar. Sie wollen noch ein bisschen schlanker sein, sie wollen im Wesentlichen den Plattformen abwarten.
Meinst du, da kommt überhaupt ein neuer Formfaktor? Also, um das alles zu machen, müsste ja auch ein neues Gehäuse kommen dann. Könnte ja auch sein, dass sie weiter mit dem Alten machen, nur die CPU updaten und das war's dann.
Ist vorstellbar, aber in gewisser Hinsicht müssen sie ja auch noch was liefern hier zum R. Also, ich meine, dieses R, ich würde mir, wenn ich heute...
Don Robert hat doch letztens gerätselt, dass es gar keine Rs mehr geben wird.
Nee, es wird, natürlich nicht. Das R läuft jetzt aus. Das werden sie jetzt noch so lange verkaufen, wie es Leute gibt, die das kaufen, weil sie sagen, das ist der geilste Computer. Also ganz ehrlich, wenn mir jetzt alle meine Rechner geklaut werden, das erste, was ich mir kaufe, ist ein 11 Zoll R. Da denke ich nicht auch nur an eine Mikrosekunde über irgendeinen Retina-Scheiß nach. Ich will genau diesen Formfaktor mit dieser Ausstattung. Das ist einfach der Computer für mich.
Also bist du mehr so mit dem SE auch schon so, brauchst du eher so die kleinen Geräte?
Ich hab hier irgendwie zwei 27 Zoll-Monitore an einem Mac Pro.
Ja, hat ja nun mal nicht jeder.
Nein, aber das ist meine Kombination. Ich will einen schlanken, leichten, schnellen Laptop mit vielen Ports haben.
Wenn sie diesen 27 Zoll-iMac kaufen, kriegen sie dieses MacBook Air dazu.
Ich finde das 11 Zoll einfach einen ganz großen Wurf. Hätte ich einen unmittelbaren Bedarf für noch größeren Bildschirme, würde ich auch sofort das 13er Air in mein Herz schließen und sagen, okay, SD-Karte, nochmal eine Dreifreihen, alles super. Ich leide jetzt nicht so sehr, ich hab hier irgendwie ein halbes G-Plattenplatz drin, das passt alles. Natürlich. Hab ich überhaupt ein halbes? Warte mal, vielleicht red ich auch nur gerade Müll. Oder habe ich 256? Nee, ich hab ja ein halbes Tee. Ein halbes Tee schleppe ich mit mir rum, alles gut. Ich liebe MacBook Air. Ich liebe MacBook Air. Ich liebe MacBook Air. Ich liebe MacBook Air.
Na, ich glaube, mein nächster Rechner wird auch wieder ein 15er sein. Weißt du gar nicht warum?
Ich liebe MacBook Air.
Also ich bin jetzt hier erfolgreich auf dem 13er gelandet. Und ich glaube, für meinen Bedarf zurück zum 15er will ich nicht. Das halbe Kilo, das ist es mir nicht wert.
Ja, da muss ich auch nochmal schwer drüber nachdenken.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, also so die Frage, was muss Apple eigentlich bringen, dass ich sage so, hey, jetzt will ich unbedingt ein neues MacBook Pro haben. So eine richtige Antwort habe ich da eigentlich gar nicht drauf. Also...
Also die sind auch so, das ist jetzt alles da, was man braucht. Geschwindigkeit, also mein Quad von vor fünf Jahren ist immer noch so scheißisch schnell. Da braucht man irgendwie, also so richtig...
Aber ich meine, es tut sich halt auf Mac auch nicht mehr so viel. Also jetzt, dass irgendwie Apple jetzt mit großartigen Neuerungen in den OS X rumgekommen wäre...
Schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht. Wenn es erstmal Mac OS heißt wieder, dann wird alles gut. Mit kleinem M oder mit großem M, was du? Ich habe...
Keine Ahnung.
Naja, man weiß ja nicht mehr als diese Leaks. Es stand auf der Webseite mit großem M.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Versehen. Ich glaube, das wird ein kleines werden, weil es passt wirklich dann auch zum iOS und so weiter.
Das wäre wirklich der ultimative OCD, wenn sie irgendwie iOS, TVOS, WatchOS, alles klein und dann ausgerechnet...
OCD Nightmare.
Ihr könnt jetzt mich und die Hörer aufklären, was OCD heißt.
Genau. Das ist so, wenn du in so ein Bad reingehst und überall sind die Fliesen gleichmäßig...
Es gab da mal...
Nur eine ist irgendwie falsch gedreht, ne?
Gibt's vielleicht immer noch so ein Twitter-Account. OCD Nightmares, der schon ganz fiese Fotos... Also selbst für jemanden, der kein OCD hat, irgendwie schwererträgliche Fotos gepostet hat von einzelnen Fliesen, die nicht passen oder sonstigen Sachen.
Wie geht denn Stream denn? Also das Slack da scheint ja weiter zu scrollen.
Siehst du das? Ich hab hier gerade nur so...
Schau mal da auf den Link, der ist auch viel besser als deiner. Der hat nämlich das andere Line mit drin und du nicht.
Achso, hab ich was falsch gemacht. Dadurch lädt das Twitter immer noch nicht hier richtig. Naja, auf jeden Fall kann ich... Ich würde das für einen großen Fehler halten. Außerdem wäre das Kleine insofern ganz praktisch, dass man dann immer noch zwischen Mac OS das Alte und Mac OS das Neue unterscheiden könnte. Die eigentliche Frage ist...
Wozu heißt Mac OS das Ganz Alte?
Wie das Ganz Alte?
Also Mac OS dein OS X und jetzt das...
Nee, es gab erst Mac OS. Erst hieß es System 6.
System 7, dann hieß es Mac OS 8, Mac OS 9, dann hieß es Mac OS X, dann hieß es OS X und jetzt kommen wir Kleine Mac OS.
Und die Nummer ist 12.
Wieso 12?
Na weil wir jetzt bei 10, 11 sind.
Ja, aber sie könnten ja von 10, 11 auf 11 gehen. Nee, nicht 10, 12, sondern nur 11.
Achso.
Das könnten sie ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das tun werden.
Warum nicht?
Na weil 11 ist halt schon durch, weil 11 ist halt Yosemite, ist Kapitan. Oder sind wir jetzt schon bei 12? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht.
Nee, wir sind auch bei 10, 11.
Also ich würde sagen, also mein Tipp ist Mac OS 12.
Also nicht 10, 12, sondern Mac OS 12?
Nein, dieses X und 10 und 10, das wird einfach, das ist einfach ein Fnord, den kriegt einfach mittlerweile keine mehr mit. Sie haben halt den Wechsel von 9 auf 10 genutzt, um die 10 sozusagen mit reinzuziehen und jetzt arbeiten wir gefühlt die ganze Zeit seit 10. Das wiederum würde dafür sprechen, es 11 zu nennen. Insofern gebe ich dir Recht, weil wir jetzt sozusagen 10 Jahre lang hatten wir 10 und jetzt können sie es 11 Jahre lang 11 nennen.
Der Witz ist, dass wenn man in Michel geht und Youname minus A macht, oder nur Youname glaube ich, dann steht ja da was von Version 15 oder so, ne? Genau, weil das nämlich das OpenStep, das hatte schon Version 4 damals, deswegen war das erste Mac OS 10.0, da war der Körner schon Version 5.
Quasi das noch nicht mehr release unter dem Namen.
Das heißt der Körner ist immer um 4 Versionen weiter als noch das eigentliche OS. Also es ist ein Versionsdrama.
Der Jet hat hier das richtige Gespür.
Ah, natürlich! Natürlich!
Oder Mac 11!
Hört ihr die Jungs da im Fahrstuhl präsentieren?
Am besten, sie holen die Jungs auf die Bühne und dann machen die das live, wie ich sag's dir.
Ich glaub, das kann auch jeder andere.
Sollen sie bitte mit kleinen Buchstaben. Sonst dreh ich durch. Mit Großbuchstaben, das passt einfach mal gar nicht.
Und meint er, die nutzen das Mac OS für den zukünftigen Rechner, der dann mit diesem Arm OS kommen wird? Oder wird dieses Mac OS jetzt ganz simpel einfach das OS X ablösen, ohne sonstige Änderungen?
Du mit deinem Arm, ne?
Ich glaube, die bringen den Arm ja nicht einfach so, sondern sie nutzen das, um halt auch das OS so dicht zu machen, wie das iOS. Also das File-System ist dann einfach mal vorbei.
Also ich glaube, dass der Arm in einem, was halt jetzt das MacBook ist, durchaus sinnvoll ist, wenn das Ding noch leichter werden soll und noch mehr Laufzeit kriegen soll. Dann hast du quasi ein iPad Pro mit Tastatur eingebaut zum Klappen und fährst aber irgendeine Art von Mac OS da drauf. Das ist sinnvoll, für alle anderen Geräte wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Und Arm wird Store Only sein, ich sag's euch.
Vielleicht auch noch für Mac Mini oder so.
App Store Only.
Das können sie sich nicht leisten, weil...
Bei der neuen Plattform mit Arm schon. Haben sie sich auf dem iPhone auch geleistet und es hat locker funktioniert.
Es gab auch nie ein anderes Modell. Der Mac App Store ja irgendwie nur noch ein Schatten seiner selbst ist.
Ja, weil es halt die Möglichkeit gibt, das auch anders zu machen. Wenn die aber das Mac OS auf Arm, wenn es da keine andere Möglichkeit gibt, dann wirst du...
Dann gehen die Leute wieder auf Windows. Das können sie sich nicht leisten.
Niemand geht mehr auf Windows.
Nein, die kaufen dann diese Geräte nicht. Dann kaufen die einfach jahrelang die Intel. Nein, bei diesem Store haben sie wirklich massiv verkackt. Bis sie das nicht komplett auf neue Beine gestellt haben, können sie es einfach mal vergessen.
Apple hat schon ganz andere Nummern durchgezogen.
Apple macht nicht alles richtig. Und Apple hat auch nicht mit allem Erfolg.
Das kann schon sein.
Schon gar nicht mit ihrer Software.
Die wollen dieses offene OS auf jeden Fall loswerden. Das ist nicht in deren Interesse.
Warum? Was ist denn so offen an diesem OS?
Na jeder kann machen, was er will. Das finden die nicht gut.
Was heißt machen, was er will?
Aus Security-Gründen nicht gut, aus Trojanern und sonstwie gründlich. Also die Leute können zu viel falsch machen. Deswegen gibt es jetzt auch schon diesen Rootless-Mode, aber der Rootless-Mode ist halt auch nicht die beste Lösung. Also auf Dauer wollen die das genauso dicht machen, wie so ein IOS.
Ja, aber nicht aus dem Grund, weil sie es den Leuten nicht gönnen, sondern aus Security-Gründen.
Die Gründe sind mir ja schnuppe. Was heißt den Leuten nicht gönnen? Das hat halt schöne Nebeneffekte. Also Security können ja sein, dass die das vorne vor sich her schieben und sagen, deswegen machen wir das. Und vielleicht glauben das auch ein paar Leute. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht der einzige Grund, sondern natürlich wollen die auch alles, was auf so einem Gerät läuft, erstens bestimmen können. Und das können sie, wenn alles durch ihren Store durch muss und verdient tun sie dann auch noch. Jetzt kommt halt irgendwie irgendeine App, sagt der Store ist blöd, wir verkaufen jetzt wieder selber und Apple verdient kein Fannich. Das finden die nicht gut, das wollen die anders haben.
Ja natürlich, aber dazu müssen sie den Store attraktiver machen, statt zu versuchen auf eine...
Guck dir an, der Store ist attraktiv.
Nein, ist er nicht.
Wenn es keine Konkurrenz gibt, dann bestellt es die Frage gar nicht.
Es gibt die Konkurrenz. Der Großteil der Software ist nicht im Store. Im Store ist nur Scheiße. In diesem Mac Store ist nur Scheiße.
Ja, OS X, weil da gibt es halt eine Alternative auf diesen Mac OS. Aber meiner Meinung nach wird es diese Alternative nicht mehr geben. Und dann musst du, und dann hast du keine Chance. Und dann werden die Developer auch, weil die sind alle Geldgeil und dann machen die das.
Nein, die können ja ihre Programme gar nicht zum Laufen bekommen mit dem Store. Das ist doch das Problem. Das funktioniert technisch nicht.
Es geht auf iOS auch alles.
iOS ist ein anderes Betriebssystem.
Der Mac OS wird auch ein anderes Betriebssystem sein.
Es gab nie keine Sandbox.
Vielleicht haben sie die bis dahin dann mal gefixt.
Das müssen sie halt erstmal machen. Und da sind sie halt noch sehr weit von entfernt. Also ich erwarte auf dieser WWDC, eigentlich müssen sie da den Kotao machen und sie müssen irgendwie sagen, ok sorry, tut uns leid, but we are fixing the App Store now.
Ja und die müssen sie natürlich für beide Plattformen fixen. Also für alle Plattformen.
Sie müssen es für beide Plattformen, aber sie müssen es vor allem für den Mac fixen. Und meiner Meinung nach müssen sie auch, ob sie es tun werden, weiß ich nicht, aber sie müssen es meiner Meinung nach tun, sie müssen einfach endlich mal ein attraktives Upgrade-Modell anbieten, was fair ist zu den Programmierern, zu den Developern und was auch fair ist für die Loser.
Das gehört zu Upstore-Fixen dazu. Demo-Versionen, bezahlte Upgrades und das dritte, ganz wichtig, der Entwickler muss endlich eine Möglichkeit haben auch zu seinen Kunden Kontakte aufzunehmen. Also das sind so die drei Dinge, die wirklich dem Upstore schwer schaden und den Mac-Upstore einfach mal abgewürgt hat.
Und da kann man sich ja alle möglichen Brücken vorstellen, wie das auch innerhalb so eines eingepferchten Ökosystems machbar ist. Gut, dann geht die Kommunikation vielleicht nur durch diesen Store durch und anonymisiert sich ein wenig und du weißt nicht genau, wer es ist, du hast nicht die Adressen und Daten, das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Aber du musst ja zumindest sprechen können, du musst ja zumindest irgendwie einen Kanal haben, der vielleicht opt in ist oder so, aber der vielleicht auch im Notfall eben auch mal forciert werden kann, wenn du wirklich jetzt ein schweres Anliegen hast, Sicherheitslücke, irgendwas muss dringend kommuniziert werden. Das ist auf jeden Fall gut so und ich fände das absolut wichtig, dass sie das machen und das müssen sie erstmal machen. Also sie haben auf dem Mac nicht die Möglichkeit, da was durchzudrücken, weil wenn sie so jetzt kommen würden, sagen würden ja, wir wissen zwar, dass unser App Store scheiße ist, aber wir drücken euch das jetzt mal aufs Auge.
Nein, das geht nicht.
Dann werden die so einen Shitstorm kriegen, die werden einfach monatelang nicht mehr aus den Nachrichten rauskommen und der Untergang wird...
So meine ich dich da gar nicht, sondern das OS X wird es weiterhin so geben, wie es jetzt ist. Dieses Mac OS ist ein Parallel-OS, meiner Meinung nach nur für Abendkisten, für sozusagen eine neue Hardware, eine neue Plattform, wo sie ihre neuen Regeln durchsetzen.
Auf keinen Fall machen sie das. Das werden sie auf gar keinen Fall tun.
Ich kann mir das richtig gut vorstellen, wie sie das machen.
Da wette ich jedes verfügbare Geld, jeden Bitcore, wenn ich habe.
Weil das ist doch, man kauft heutzutage nicht mehr so einen Rechner, der irgendwie alles kann, man kauft so eine Art... Wie heißt das dann? Appliance, wenn sie nur bestimmte Sachen kann und nicht kaputt gehen kann und so weiter. Das wird so ein armes Ding ins Mac OS Teil werden.
Das haben sie schon, das heißt iOS.
Ja, aber das ist noch nicht gut genug.
Ja, aber dass das nicht gut genug ist, liegt nicht daran, dass es jetzt zu offen ist oder so, sondern das nicht gut genug ist, liegt daran, dass der Upstore scheiße ist und dass die Developer nicht genug Geld damit verdienen können, mal irgendwie amtliche Software zu machen. Weißt du, so...
Gute Programme auf dem Mac sind derzeit einfach nicht auch nur im Ansatz in dem Maße verfügbar, wie das für iOS ist, selbst wenn du jetzt die Zahlen anpasst. Für iOS gibt es sehr viele sehr gute Titel, für den Mac gibt es extrem wenig. Da sind jetzt so 2, 3, 4, 5 Programme rausgekommen in der letzten Zeit.
Du meinst im Store?
Überhaupt. Wie überhaupt? Sag mir doch mal neue Apps auf dem Mac. Sag mir doch mal, was da jetzt wirklich groß gekommen ist. Das ist alles sehr, sehr, sehr überschaubar. Das hat nicht mal die Dynamik, die du unter MacOS hattest damals. Also da passiert einfach nicht viel. Vor allem, es gibt keinerlei Drive unter iOS. Gibt es für jeden Scheißdienst eine App auf dem Mac?
Ja, aber das liegt natürlich daran, dass die Dienste, sind ja alles internetbasierte Dienste. Und die brauchen entweder ein Web-Frontend, was sowieso schon sackt, was du dann unter einem mobilen Browser benutzt, was noch mehr sackt. Aber du kannst halt mit relativ wenig Aufwand eine App schreiben, die jetzt mit dem Internetdienst spricht und ein ziemlich cooles Interface macht. Wenn du allerdings auf dem Mac das einfach nur die Webseite benutzt, auf einem großen Display.
Die User Experience. Daran genau zeigt sich das doch. Die User Experience, die du im Webbrowser hast, ist doch im Vergleich zu der User Experience in einer App überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen.
Ja gut, aber Slack benutzt ja Webviews hinten und vorne. Das sieht ja nicht anders aus unter iOS, als es im Browser aussieht.
Sie benutzen hier so ein spezielles Web-Framework.
So ein externes, nicht von Apple meinst du das schon?
Ja, ich hab jetzt den Namen leider vergessen. Der Chat wird es mir gleich erzählen.
Da gibt es so ein paar, ja. Nein, du hast ja natürlich Recht. Twitter ist jetzt noch so das einzige, wo jetzt auf dem Mac native Clients existieren. Aber ich meine, willst du jetzt für Xing-native Clients auf dem Mac haben? Willst du jetzt für Facebook?
Für Srima zum Beispiel, für alle meine Messenger hätte ich gerne auf jeden Fall schon mal eine native Client. Das ist so ganz klar der Bereich, wo ich überhaupt keinen Bock habe.
Wie viel würdest du denn dafür zahlen?
Mit irgendwie einem Web-Browser. Wofür?
Für den native Client auf dem Mac.
Für welches Programm? Na ja, abgesehen, dass Srima noch nicht so ganz meine Usability-Vorstellungen entgegenkommt, aber es dann vielleicht etwas erträglicher werden könnte. Keine Ahnung, 5-10 Euro.
Ja, siehst du, genau das ist das Problem. Weil du natürlich auf dem Mac nicht die Verkaufszahlen von IOS hast. Das heißt, du musst die Entwicklungsaufwand, den du hast, auf weniger User verteilen. Und deswegen ist es automatisch teurer. Du kannst nicht für 5 Euro ein Srima client auf dem Mac halten, das ist für unrealistisch.
Warum?
Weil du den nicht kostendeckend anbieten kannst für 5 Euro.
Ja, aber warum muss man den nicht kostendeckend anbieten?
Hab ich gerade erklärt, weil die Kundschaft nicht so groß ist. Du müsstest dafür 20 nehmen. Du findest es wichtig, den meisten Leuten geht ein Srima-Client auf dem Mac halt auch am Arsch vorbei.
Würde ich nicht sagen.
Ich schon.
Mir geht ja nicht nur am Arsch vorbei, sondern ich will auch nicht das andere in haben, weil die ballern mich dann nur mit Text zu. Es ist schon so schlimm, was da im Srima passiert. In der nächsten Revolution wird ein Srima stattfinden.
Du hast natürlich auf dem Mac diese ganze Klasse von Applikationen, die relativ komplex sind. So kreative Apps. Wann hatten wir Sketch? Hatten wir irgendwann? Sowas gibt es nicht für iOS.
Nein, das ist ja klar. Wir reden über zwei Sachen. Dass dieses Klein-App-Phänomen auf dem Mac nicht da ist. Du hast das ja noch nicht mal bei Sachen, die kostenlos sind. Wo es darum geht, dass das überhaupt den Zugang und die Nutzung des Dienstes der letzten Endes im Backend sein Geld verdient, dass du diese Nutzung so einfach wie möglich machen willst. Da kommen sie dann halt auf dem Desktop alle mit irgendwelchen Webfrontends dir einfach saugen. Während sie halt auf dem Telefon das nicht tun, weil sie wissen, dass eine App sich einfacher benutzen lässt. Aber das ist halt auch auf Mac so, dass sich das einfacher benutzen lässt.
Das ist aber eine Marktdynamik, die ganz anders funktioniert. Dieses Mobile First, Mobile Only, um mal so Bullshit-Bingo-Begriffe zu bringen, was halt so in der Business-Welt grassiert. Da ist es halt so, dass du in der Gefahr bist, an deinen Konkurrenten zu verlieren, wenn du keine mobile App hast für deinen Dienst. Die cool aussieht, die irgendwie schnittig ist und den User schnell die Sachen machen lässt. Aber auf dem Desktop kräht da kein Hahn danach. Du verlierst deinen Dienst nicht an den Konkurrenten, nur weil du keinen nativen Mac-Client hast.
Bei Messengers würde ich das jetzt nicht so sehen. Also das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht der wichtigste Aspekt.
Offensichtlich hat Slack ja einen quasi nativen...
Das ist kein Messenger.
Das ist Chat. Ja, Chat, Messenger, Textnachrichten.
Geht in eine ähnliche Richtung. Ich gebe das zu.
Das sind jetzt philosophische Unterschiede. Du hast für AIM, für Jabber, für ICQ, für diese ganzen Protokolle, hast du Messenger. Native Messenger. Also ja, für 3MAR halt nicht. Aber das ist halt auch ein proprietäres, quasi geschlossenes System. Und für dieses, was gerade so in Mode ist, das Verschlüsselte, wie heißt denn das? Signal, genau. Dafür hast du doch auch einen Client, oder? So einen nativen Client.
Das ist einer jetzt angekündigt, dass jetzt mal bald mal einer kommt. Der ist irgendwie in Beta. Und es gibt für Facebook einen Third-Party-Client, der nicht komplett sagt, aber halt auch unklar ist, was der so für eine Zukunft hat. Die werden dann meistens so lange entwickelt, bis sie nicht mehr entwickelt werden. Ja, ich weiß schon, wie die Dynamiken sind. Ich will auf was anderes hinaus. Ich finde, Apple muss sich trotzdem extrem viel Mühe geben, das Entwickeln von Apps auf Mac A einfacher werden zu lassen. Da sind sie gegebenenfalls dran mit Zwift. Und vielleicht werden wir schon auf dieser WWDC einen großen neuen Schub in Richtung neue Framework-Welt sehen. Würde mich jetzt nicht wundern.
Zu hoffen ist das.
Würde mich jetzt auch nicht wundern, wenn es noch nicht so weit ist. Aber ich wäre jetzt nicht komplett erschlagen, wenn sie so etwas ankündigen, wie jetzt wisst ihr ja, wo es hingeht mit Zwift, jetzt kommt hier Version 3.1. 3.0 kommt zur WWDC. Ok, und jetzt ist irgendwie alles stable. Und jetzt haben wir das auch selber genug durchgekaut.
Du wirst zur WWDC die ersten Betas von 3.0 kriegen. Und irgendwann im Herbst hast du dann die stabile fertige 3.0.
Sind die Features da schon bekannt?
Ich hab so den Eindruck, das ist ja open source und der ganze Entwicklungsprozess ist open. Also kannst du ja gucken, weil Github.
Also ich glaube, dass sie mit Zwift müssten sie jetzt intern so weit sein. Ich meine, als sie es vorgestellt haben, haben sie schon 4, 5 Jahre dran genagt.
Genau.
Jetzt haben sie noch mal 3 Jahre drüber nachgedacht. Und viele Leute haben mit ihnen mit nachgedacht. Und sie haben jetzt so einen Prozess. Und sie werden sicherlich selber jetzt einschätzen können, ob sie das Gefühl haben, dass sie irgendwie noch nicht am Ziel sind. Oder ob sie sozusagen langsam die Richtung...
Hast du die WWDC-Einladung gesehen? Swift is the thing.
Was steht da?
Die ist so auf Texts, Code-Eingabedings mit...
Ich dachte nur, Siri hat diese Nachricht verteilt. Gibt es da auch ein Bild dazu?
Nein, es gibt auf der Webseite dieses...
So ein Code-Fenster, schwarzer Syntex-Coloring, irgendwie Swift-Code.
Genau, und das ist alles Swift-Code.
Oder Hello-WWDC sogar, ich weiß gar nicht.
Hello-WWDC und dann gibt es so Register, sonst was.
Ich hab hier irgendwie gerade...
Hallo, ist das Netzwerk Fu?
Nö, nur mein Browser macht irgendwie Müll.
Wahrscheinlich ist er bei der 8 GB Grenze angekommen.
Ich glaub, der ist einfach durch. Ja, den Gedanken nochmal kurz zu Ende gebracht.
Also, was ich sagen will, ist... Kein Hahn kräht bei Apple mehr nach Objective-C. Das ist durch. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sie zur WWDC sagen, ok, ab heute ist das Legacy.
Das sagen die bestimmt.
Ab heute ist das Legacy, wir machen da sonst nichts mehr.
Also sie machen vielleicht noch was, aber Vorträge und so ist alles nur noch Swift-only.
Ja, das war ja schon letzte WWDC, alle Vorträge Swift-only, aber sie werden vielleicht auch so was sagen wie alle neuen Frameworks nur noch Swift, alle, was weiß ich, und überhaupt, und das ist jetzt deprecated und...
Da haben sie aber auch angesagt, dass sie das nicht so schnell machen wollen.
Ja gut, kann natürlich sein.
Also ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, dass dieses deprecated, das wird sehr lange dauern.
Ich glaube auch.
Also mindestens fünf Jahre, bevor sie irgendwas richtig aktiv über Bord schmeißen, im Sinne von wir unterstützen Objective-C nicht mehr, weil du musst auch davon ausgehen, dass du einfach einen Shitload an Programmierern hast, die vielleicht so eher EOL sind, ja? Aber die sagen wir mal noch bis zum Ende ihrer Rente allein schon genug damit zu tun haben, existierenden Code zu maintainen.
Das Problem ist eigentlich ein anderes. In Objective-C hast du dieses dynamische Message Dispatch, wie es so schön heißt. Also du kannst zur Laufzeit sagen, wie deine Methode ist, die du aufrufen willst. Und das hast du in Swift nicht. Und es gibt eine Klasse von Problemen, die kriegst du nur mit Dynamic Dispatch tatsächlich gelöst. Viel von dem Testkram und ich tausche im Hintergrund irgendwelche Klassen aus und tu so, als wäre das noch die alte Klasse und so. Das funktioniert mir nur mit diesem Dynamic Dispatch. Und es kann sein, dass da noch ein bisschen Zeit ins Land gehen muss, bis sie wirklich sagen können, okay, das machen wir jetzt wirklich nicht mehr. Ja, vor allen Dingen Core Data ist so ein Ding. Da hack ich ja gerne drauf rum. Aber mal ganz ehrlich, das gesamte Konstrukt, wie Core Data funktioniert, wäre in Swift gar nicht zu machen. Du könntest Core Data so, wie es ist, nicht in Swift schreiben.
Geht nicht.
Weil das alles auf dynamischem Message Passing basiert.
Ja gut, ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus. Und zwar, ich denke, dass sie mittelfristig irgendwann mal ein komplett neues Konzept vorstellen müssen, wie sie Apps auf Mac erstellt haben wollen. Und die Sprache war der erforderliche technologische Grundlagenbau, um das zu ermöglichen. Teilweise, weil die Features in irgendeiner Form von Sprachfeatures von Swift abhängen, bzw. dass du die Effizienz hinbekommst. Oder anders ausgedrückt, es ist dann auch einfacher, neues Framework abhängig von der Sprache. Da ist dann eben wirklich auch der Cut. Das heißt, wenn du auf das neue Modell gehst, wenn du die neue einfache Art und Weise Apps zu bauen, die sehr viel mehr sich borgt aus der iOS-Welt, aber vielleicht auch ein paar Lehren daraus. Ich meine, die Plattform ist ja nun mittlerweile auch fast 10 Jahre alt. Das halt alles zusammennimmt. Und vielleicht, drehen wir mal nicht durch, sogar ein Unified-Model anstrebt für iOS und macOS in irgendeiner Form.
Du gehst aber davon aus, dass iOS und macOS in der Art, wie Apps gebaut werden, sich signifikant voneinander unterscheiden würden. Dem ist allerdings nicht so. Das ist im Prinzip der gleiche Scheiß nur, dass iOS an vielen Ecken und Enden alte Zöpfe abgeschnitten hat und Sachen ein bisschen besser macht. Aber im Großen und Ganzen stecken die gleichen Konzepte dahinter. Wenn du jetzt sagst, du willst ein ganz neues Konzept, wie man Apps baut, dann viel Glück. Aber wenn sie da schreiben, let www.dc16 gleich Game Changing, ja, vielleicht...
Vielleicht ist ja macOS auch neusweisend Swift gecodet. Weil sie haben gesagt, die Swift ist so designt, dass man damit auch in den US machen könnte.
Und unter Garantie wollen sie das machen.
Und ich meine nicht nur die Framework, sondern auch den Kernel nehme ich mal an.
Naja gut, der Kernel wird weiterhin in den C++ geschrieben sein.
Das wird mehr davon gemacht.
Sicherlich, sie werden das schrittweise bestimmt tun. Allein aus Sicherheitsgründen. Sie wollen halt einfach die Security einfach nailen und da ist es sicherlich sinnvoll, das von ganz unten noch mal komplett neu zu denken. Da ist ja auch glaube ich viel.
Ich sag noch Go To Fail, ne? Das war ja mal so ein klassischer C-Fail.
Hilft auf jeden Fall schon mal so ein komplettes Compiler-Subsystem zu haben mit einer Sprache, wo wirklich vollkommen klar ist zu jedem Zeitpunkt, wo welcher Typ ist. Und was was ist. Also wenn wirklich so jeder, jedes Objekt zu jedem Zeitpunkt vollständig identifizierbar ist und einfach klar ist, was in diesem Speicher ist, das kann durchaus dazu beitragen, ein System sicherer zu machen.
Nee, die Sicherheit, die zusätzliche, die Swift bringt, ist, dass halt einfach C ist jetzt über 40 Jahre alt. Da sind halt viele Sachen drin, die wurden nie gefixt. Swift fixt sie halt.
Ja, unter anderem dadurch, dass du halt einfach durchgehendes, ja nicht nur solche Sachen, sondern dass einfach auch die Runtime wirklich bis ins Allerletzte einfach immer genau weiß, womit das zu tun hat. Was bei C halt einfach bei Design nicht der Fall ist.
Weil C keine Runtime hat.
Genau. Weil es halt auch bei Design halt alles offen lässt. Ja, Charpointer, Voidpointer. So, trotzdem kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie auch in wie vielen Jahren, seit wann gibt es Next Step jetzt, Ende der 80er Jahre, also das ist jetzt so...
Ja, 90er, 90, ich würde sagen 90.
Na, sie haben Ende der 80er angefangen, so 88, 99.
Naja, aber 08 oder so kam, glaube ich, 90 aus.
Ja, aber da haben sie dieses Konzept erdacht. Dass die Art und Weise, wie du...
Du meinst, das ist ganz überholt, ja?
Natürlich ist es überholt.
Ja gut, es hat da auch immer wieder Änderungen gegeben. So ist es nicht. Ja, es ist wieder überholt, aber...
Lass mich doch einfach mal ausreden. Ich sage nur, ich erwarte, dass sie mittelfristig diese Erfahrungen so zusammenbauen, dass sie sagen, wir gehen jetzt hier einen neuen Schritt und wir haben jetzt hier eine neue Art und Weise, die vielleicht von solchen Ideen wie React sich eine ganze Menge zurücktankt. Dass du einfach noch weniger auf Details deines Programms achten musst und dass das Betriebssystem dir das abnimmt. Ich meine, erinnere dich, früher bei macOS mussten Programme auf so, wie hießen diese Events, ein Fenster, was vor dir lag, ist zur Seite geschoben worden und du musstest irgendwie einen Teil deines Fensters wieder neu erinnern.
Du redest jetzt von System 7?
Von macOS, ja. Ja, aber so war das mal. Und heutzutage...
Ja, das kommt aber aus den Anfang der 80er, die Konzepte. Next kommt halt aus den Anfang der 90er.
Genau, und da hast du dann halt irgendwie so ein Double Buffering-System und jetzt musstest du dir sozusagen nicht mehr über solche Freiräummodelle Gedanken machen. Aber du musst dir heute immer noch über sehr viele andere Sachen Gedanken machen, die das Programmieren einfach schwierig werden lassen.
Das Freiräummodell hat OS X in Coco tatsächlich noch drin. Wer es nicht mehr hat, ist halt iOS. Weil bei iOS wirklich im Prinzip jeder View mehr oder weniger eine Textur auf der Grafikkarte ist. Das heißt, du hast die Frage, ob du irgendwas neu zeichnen musst, stellt sich nicht mehr, weil es ist immer eine Extra-Textur irgendwo. Gute West-Technologie. Ne, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass sie in Sachen Funktionale gehen. React ist ja auch so ein bisschen funktional. Also Swift bringt alles mit, um Funktionalprogrammierung zu machen. Aber ob's... weiß man nicht.
Was wir mal fixen könnten ist, dass man, wenn ich im Menü bin, dass dann das Programm nicht stehen bleibt.
Ja, das ist das, was ich vorhin schon meinte, das ist halt das mit dem Main-Thread.
Das geht zum Beispiel gar nicht.
Also, das ist nicht cool, aber da muss man...
Das Next Step kommt aus einer Zeit, wo es halt keine Multicore-Prozessoren gab. Da hast du alles in einem Thread gemacht. Und da kommt ja auch letzten Endes das ganze objektorientierte Programmieren her.
Du musst das Programm nicht stehen bleiben, wenn ich im Menü bin und nix mache im Menü, sondern nur aufklappe, da muss nix stehen bleiben.
Und aus dem, ich hab nur einen Thread, kommt ja auch diese bekloppte Idee der Exceptions her. Also, sobald du mehr als einen Thread hast, machen Exceptioner nur noch so bedingt Sinn. Weil du die nicht von einem Thread zum anderen kriegst. Das ist irgendwie so...
Also, wir sehen, das ist schon eine Menge da, was man da designtechnisch auch mal anders machen könnte.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich könnte meinen Finger jetzt auch nicht so direkt in die Wunde legen, was es jetzt ist, was man jetzt...
Nee, da muss man sich schon auch ein bisschen länger ansetzen. Das ist ja halt eben das Ding mit dem Design. Man setzt sich vor allem ein und überlegt man eine Weile, wie es halt schick sein soll. Und was hat Steve Jobs gesagt, als OS. Tenn rauskam, dass es das OS für die nächsten 20 Jahre sein wird. Das waren seine Worte, 20 Jahre. Nee, es kam ja 2001 raus. Es sind jetzt 15 um. Aber dann müsste man jetzt schon langsam mal nachdenken und vorbereiten, was dann in 5 Jahren das ablösen wird. Okay, und die müssen sich jetzt ja auch nicht auf die Kommastellen an Steve's Worte halten. Aber nach 20 Jahren kann so ein OS schon auch mal abgelöst werden.
Das ist aber realistisch, finde ich. Also, ja, in 5 Jahren jetzt mal wirklich mal die neuen Konzepte, die sich bis dahin entwickelt haben, mal durchziehen, das wäre dann schon mal angesagt. Naja, wir hatten, was wir jetzt die ganze Zeit noch nicht gesagt haben zum Thema Swift, die Google-Jungs haben es geportet auf Android.
Wirklich die Google-Jungs oder irgendwer?
Das ist nicht so ganz klar, aber ich denke mal schon, dass es Google gibt.
Da gab es vor ein paar Wochen Gerüchte, dass eventuell Swift irgendwie, dass Google Swift für Android nehmen will.
Naja, also sagen wir mal so, die paar Leute, die daran gearbeitet haben, haben erfolgreich ihren Pull-Request in den Main-Branch bekommen. Also Android Support ist jetzt auf dem Main-Branch von Swift. Also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie Pläne oder irgendwas, sondern das ist da jetzt drin. Wie gut das jetzt funktioniert.
Das wäre ja nicht die erste Technologie.
Vor fünf Tagen in Main-Branch gemercht ist wahrscheinlich auch noch sehr rauhe See, aber immerhin.
Wäre nicht die erste Technologie, wo Google in was einsteigt, was Apple angefangen hat und dann am Ende sogar erfolgreicher benutzt. Also wenn man sich das Web-Kit anguckt.
Naja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie so wie alle anderen auch von Oracle ganz schön angepisst sind.
So ist das halt, wenn man Zeug von jemand anderem benutzt, der die Rechte hat.
Also jetzt von Java wegzugehen auf Swift wäre jetzt für Google zumindest dann, wenn sie es schaffen, licensing-mäßig mit Apple einen vernünftigen Deal zu machen.
Sie brauchen ja noch nicht mal einen Deal machen, oder? Wenn das open ist, ist es open.
Ja, irgendwelche Rechte wird es da schon geben. Also keine Ahnung.
Dann ist es nicht richtig open.
Was ist jetzt?
Wir müssen vorankommen in dieser Diskussion.
Wir kommen voran.
Okay, da bin ich ja beruhigt.
Nicht schneller oder langsamer als den restlichen die letzten zwei, drei Stunden. Okay, wir können ja was Erfrischendes zwischendurch machen. http://classicprogrammerpaintings.com Du kommst mit deinem Rechner ja nicht mehr so richtig voran, ne? Ich mach mal hier den in...
Die Telekom hat gerade den transparenten Proxy eingeschaltet und der funktioniert bei Terminate.
Hier geistert seit ein paar Tagen durchs Netz die Classic Programmer Paintings, wo jemand klassische oder nicht ganz so klassische Gemälde mit Programmierer spezifischen Captions unterlegt.
Das hab ich auch gesehen, aber das war doch gar nicht so interessant, oder?
Ich fand die relativ witzig, muss ich sagen. Also klar kann man jeder so sehen, wie er will.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Können wir aber hier nicht machen, weil unsere Zuschauer haben kein Video, weil wir sind immer noch ein Podcast und kein Vidcast.
Ja, ist richtig, aber ich hab's in den Chat geschmissen, es ist gepinnt, es wird in den Show Notes auftauchen. Da könnt ihr euch das angucken, das ist sehr lustig. Finde ich zumindest.
Ich muss hier mal auf den anderen DNS-Server umsteigen. Irgendwas ist hier gerade brown.
Welchen hats du denn? Den, den die Telekom unterschiebt?
So, waren wir jetzt noch irgendwie zum Schluss, wo wir sowieso gerade so viel über Apple reden, noch mal irgendwie...
Noch mal? Über? War noch was?
40 Jahre Apple haben wir irgendwie, aber wir haben eigentlich schon relativ viel über die Zukunft gesprochen.
Die kamen ganz schön viele vor davon, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Ich meine, so ein bisschen mit diesen... mit diesen Jubiläen, das ist natürlich immer so eine Sache.
Ja, aber ich meine, was willst du jetzt da groß erzählen? Das sind 40 Jahre, Apple hat nicht mal groß was dazu gemacht.
Na doch, dieses eine Video.
Ja, dieses 40 Jahre und 40 Sekunden?
Das war nicht ziemlich schlecht.
Na ja, ziemlich schlecht, würde ich nicht sagen, aber es ist jetzt auch nichts, worüber man lange reden muss, oder?
Nee, es ist halt einfach so eine Aufzählung der Dinge, die ihnen da so eingefallen ist über die Zeit.
Ja, in Bildform.
Aber trotzdem schon krass, dass es den Laden echt schon so lange gibt. Mittlerweile ist das signifikant und man kann irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig davon sprechen, dass diese ganze Computerindustrie eine junge Industrie ist. Es gibt so manche Industrien, die sind jetzt so viel älter, auch nicht. Und von daher...
Bubble Tea war schneller weg.
Das gibt es nicht mehr. Ich habe es nie getrunken, keine Ahnung.
Das war schneller weg als es da war.
Hast nichts verpasst.
Ja, davon gehe ich aus, sonst gäbe es es ja noch.
Dann gibt es wahrscheinlich auch noch. Es ist gerade bloß nicht so heipig. Wenn Sommer ist, gibt es auch wieder Bubble Tea.
Vielleicht sollte ich es dann einfach mal probieren, dann weiß ich, kann ich zumindest mitreden.
Ich habe das auch noch nie getrunken. Es fiel mir nur so ein als eine Sache, die auch schnell wieder weg war. Vielleicht war Google Wave sogar schneller.
Na, Google Wave war...
Aber Google ist ja noch da, so ist es nicht.
Google Wave hat so zwei bis drei Pingen lang durchgehalten.
Wie alt ist Google eigentlich inzwischen?
99.
War da nicht noch Alta Vista?
Wie? Alta Vista gab es da bestimmt noch. Vielleicht gibt es Alta Vista.
Alta Vista ist nicht gleich platte gegangen, wo Google das erste Mal das Licht der Welt erseht hat. Also 27. September 1998 sind die online gegangen als Google.
Hat es aber noch ein bisschen gedauert, bis sie groß wurden oder bis sie auch eine Firma gegründet haben. Das war noch keine Firma zu dem Zeitpunkt, oder? Das war doch auch so ein Uni-Projekt, oder wie?
Ich glaube, 1998 wurde es dann halt Google. Und vorher hieß es irgendwie Back Rub, was auch immer das heißt. Rass mir den Rücken, aber mach mich nicht nass, oder was? Äh, ne, das passt nicht.
Gut, da sind ja auch schon wieder 17 oder 18 Jahre am Start.
Geht ja.
Ja, wobei die auch noch irgendwie immer noch sehr umtriebig sind. Also man kann jetzt nicht gerade vorwerfen, dass sie untätig geblieben sind.
Google ist noch sehr umtriebig, sagtest du gerade?
Ja.
Ja doch, das kann man so sagen. Sie versuchen sehr viel.
Nicht jede Behauptung lässt sich hier ohne weiteres halten, aber die geht glaube ich durch. Ich weiß auch nicht, wir können ja mal in unsere Gefühlskiste kramen. Wir sind ja auch alle so olle...
Ich weiß übrigens, was du vergessen hast, was ganz wichtig ist, was ins MacBook Pro rein muss.
Meister der Ablenkung.
Deswegen sagt das ja auch schon gar nicht mehr. Und das andere, was wir schon nicht mehr erwähnen, was auf der WWDC auch nicht kommen wird, ist ein neues Pfeilsystem. Das haben wir ja auch schon. Also wir reden ja schon gar nicht mehr drüber, haben es ja aufgegeben.
Das habe ich nicht aufgegeben, das wird kaum...
Ja gut, Pfeilsystem ist natürlich wirklich was, wo du keinen Schnellschuss hinlegen möchtest. Das muss solider sein als der Körner.
Also mittlerweile traue ich ihnen zu, dass sie was komplett Eigenes entwickeln. Und es wird sehr viel mehr ihren eigenen Bedürfnissen entstiegen sein als ihr ZFS. Aber sie werden sicherlich viel von diesem Gedankengut da reinmachen, aber sie werden das Paaren mit speicherschonender Betrieb, CPU-schonender Betrieb und das ist halt einfach ZFS nicht so. Und sie werden sich nur die Perlen rausnehmen, die wirklich wichtig und erforderlich sind. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach vor allem erstmal Check-Zooming. Also ohne das können sie es einfach komplett sein.
Also CPU-intensiv ist jetzt so ein ZFS nicht. Also da die Black-Roll, also diese Kiste, die ich da mache, die hat mit 350 Megabit die Sekunde sich durchgecheckt, weil alle vier Platten gleichzeitig liest. Und das hat irgendwie 3% der CPU gekostet und die CPU ist 9 Jahre alt.
Aber RAM braucht es viel.
RAM braucht es schon viel, ja.
Aber wo wart ihr, als ihr wohl 32 GB im Laptop haben, dann ist ZFS auch interessant.
Dieses Fallsystem muss ja auch für ein Telefon funktionieren. Das muss auch in so einem iPhone funktionieren.
Das wiederum halte ich für einen Trugschluss, dass sie unbedingt ein Fallsystem brauchen, was sie auf allen Systemen einsetzen.
Sie werden bestimmt jetzt nicht mit zwei verschiedenen Fallsystemen in die Zukunft in den Sonnenuntergang marschieren. Auf gar keinen Fall werden sie das tun. Also wenn sie HFS auf dem Mac killen, dann ist es überall angezählt. Das wird vielleicht nicht gleich von heute auf morgen weg sein und es wird dann eine Übergangsphase geben von zwei Jahren.
Das wird eine verdammt lange Übergangsphase geben.
Aber nirgendwo können sie das so leicht tauschen wie unter iPhone.
Allein schon die restlichen iPods, die sind auf Verkauf.
Ist hier bekannt, was auf dem iPhone für ein File-System drauf ist? Ist das auch bewiesen irgendwie oder ist das nur so eine Vermutung?
Das ist alles, was ich bisher gehört habe.
Nee, früher konnte man ja diese... Gab es nicht eine Weile, wo man die Images tatsächlich aufmachen konnte, die da irgendwie installiert wurden und dann hat es... Naja, egal.
Es ist HFS Plus, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Es gibt ja auch kein anderes Fallsystem, was es sein könnte. Aber es ist ein Fallsystem. So, aber nirgendswo können sie den Change so schnell machen. Also sie können, morgen könnten sie ihr ZFS Lite unter iOS installieren und es würde kein Programm merken. Auf dem Mac wiederum, not so much. Allein schon, weil du halt tonnenweise SD-Karten, Festplatten und so weiter hast, auf denen noch jahrzehntelang HFS Plus rumliegen wird und das müssen sie natürlich alles irgendwie berücksichtigen und sie müssen natürlich so ein Aufwärtsding finden, wenn sie halt modern formatierten Kram an alte Rechner anschließen.
Wie ist denn das? Unterstützt eigentlich ein aktuelles Mac OS noch HFS Nicht Plus? Was ist denn?
Das ist ja im Wesentlichen das Gleiche mit kleineren Blöcken und kürzeren Dateinamen und so.
Ja, ein bisschen anders ist es schon, aber ja.
Nicht sehr viel anders.
Nicht sehr viel anders, das stimmt.
Das könnte man ja mal ausprobieren, aber kriegt man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr formatiert, ohne so einen Urheberrechner zu haben.
Andersrum ist halt die Frage, wie es läuft, und da läuft es halt irgendwie, ja, unklar. Wollen wir fertig machen, Jungs?
Eine Kleinigkeit habe ich noch, aber es ist wirklich noch eine Kleinigkeit. Ihr hattet letztes Mal nochmal über Homebrew gesprochen.
Hatten wir.
Und ich bin da über einen Guiglind gestolpert, der heißt Cakebrew. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man haben muss, aber wer wirklich lieber Guiglind macht als Kommandozeile, der kann sich Cakebrew mal angucken.
Hat sich da schon irgendwas getan, irgendwie?
Ach, der macht ab und zu mal Updates, aber...
Ach so, ich kriege hier eh gerade keine.
Was läuft mit deinem Netz?
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwas ist hier vollkommen braun, bestehende, ich kriege irgendwie gerade keinen DNS mehr raus.
Aber Stream tut er noch, oder was?
Na, bestehende Verbindungen sind... Brauchen halt keinen DNS, aber wenn ich irgendwas neu starte...
Einfach mal den Standard Google auf die Schnelle?
Nee, ich werde jetzt, hab ich schon, geht auch nicht.
Echt?
Ich komme irgendwie gerade hier gar nicht raus. Wahrscheinlich sind gerade Hacker anwesend oder so. Aber erzähl doch mal was kurz zu Cakebrew, damit wir dann langsam auch die Sendung bedanken.
Viel kann man dazu nicht sagen. Die letzte Version ist vom 22. Februar dieses Jahres, also da passiert noch irgendwas. Bringt so die üblichen Funktionen mit. Was ich ganz nett fand, ist, dass du halt für dieses Bundle, also dieses Brew-Bundle-Ding tatsächlich deine Cakebrew, also deine Homebrew, was du alles installiert hast, als Homebrew-Bundle-File exportieren kannst, um es dann woanders wieder zu installieren. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist jetzt nicht viel dabei. Es ist halt ein GUI-Client, der Frontend ist für das Binary. Also es ist nur, wer halt kein, wer Kommandozeile nicht mag, für den ist es gut.
Auf meinem Phone geht aber noch alles, also der Netz muss schon funktionieren.
Ja, aber ich werde jetzt nicht anfangen, auf meinem Produktionsrecording-Rechner während der Sendung jetzt hier irgendwelche IP-Tests zu machen, weil dann ist der Stream halt unter Umständen weg. Aber ich finde, wir sollten uns diesem Stream sowieso jetzt entziehen, weil ich werde krank und ich bin müde und......genervt. Ich hab auch den Eindruck, wir haben alles gesagt. Oder?
Wir haben nie alles gesagt. Wie ganz am Anfang jemand im Chat so schön feststellte, am Anfang der Sendung heißt es immer, wir haben keine Themen und am Ende der Sendung heißt es immer, das machen wir alles nächstes Mal. Also insofern, es ist nie alles gesagt, aber das ist auch okay so, wir können die Sendung jetzt beenden.
Ja, weil sonst geht es ja nicht weiter, sonst wird das ja alles zu dick.
Es geht immer irgendwie weiter.
Aber was ich vorhin noch sagen wollte, du meintest, das ist jetzt fehl am Platz. Mit diesen riesengroßen Gigabyte Movies muss man gar nicht mehr machen, man muss nur bei seiner berühmten Torrent-Suchmaschine X265 eingeben und dann kommen die Rips mit dem neuen Codec und das ist ja so geil und so klein, ist der Hammer. Also ich gucke jetzt wieder 350 Megabyte große Serienfolgen, die eine Stunde gehen und die Quality ist phänomenal. Also 1080p, riesengroß, 350 Megabyte.
Und das spielt zählenmäßig mit was ab?
Na auf meinem MacBook Pro, was jetzt bei Apple in der Schublade liegt.
Kann auch iOS das schon abspielen?
Weiß nicht, also das VLC müsste das eigentlich können, ja.
Nee, ich meine kann iOS das abspielen? Kann iOS schon ein H206?
Das glaube ich nicht, außerdem die Dinger, die man erladen kann, sind alles Matroschka-Dingels und so, MKVs. Ich weiß nicht, ob die, also habe ich noch nicht probiert. Müsste mal wer probieren, vielleicht können die das, aber...
Einfach mal ein MP4-Container rüber schubsen. Das machen wir ein nächstes Mal.
Die Hörer machen das, Hausaufgabe.
Genau, Hausaufgabe, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ja, in diesem Sinne.
Nächstes Mal dann vielleicht mit wieder einer vollständigeren Besetzung.
Auf jeden Fall. Huckel muss vom Spiel erzählen und Clemens von seinen Lustreisen.
Vom Spiel kannst du jetzt erzählen, kannst du ja mal gucken. Oder hast du nicht geguckt, was da stand?
Ja, er hat verloren.
Sehr lame. Zu Hause, im eigenen Stadion.
Wo sind sie?
Woanders dicke Wind und zu Hause dann...
So läuft's. Wir sagen Tschüss.
Bye bye. Stahlrechnungstechnologie? In der Lüfte?
In Skolsk?
11! 11! Das ist irisch, nicht amerikanisch. Nein, ist es nicht?
11!
Ich bin verzeihert, können Sie das bitte wiederholen? Du kannst es nicht. Ist das dein Smart-House?
Smart-House! Wenn du nicht die Lingo verstehst, kommst du nachher zu deinem Land.
Oh, was ist das jetzt? Dann kommst du wieder nach deinem Land.
Oh, start nicht, Mr. Bleedinger, wie kannst du rassistisch zu einer Liste sein? Sie sagen es nur auf der selben Art. Warum sagt man, dass man ruhig sein soll? Weil sie wussten, dass die schottischen Leute für viel Zeit auf der Sitzung gehen würden.
Ihr habt nicht ein Zimmer ausgesucht.
Ich habe ein 11!
Wenn ihr aus dem Elevator gehen möchtet, ohne einen Flur zu wählen, sagt ihr einfach, dass ihr die Türen öffnen.